[Musique]
Alain Chouet, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bah succintement, ça va être difficile
parce que j'ai une vie un peu
compliquée, mais disons bon, je suis né
en 1946.
Euh ça, je commence à être un vieux
monsieur. Euh je me j'ai fait des études
de droit, de sciences politiques et de
langues orientales avec quelques
diplômes à la clé. Et je suis rentré à
la DGS 1972 après mon service militaire.
J'y suis entré comme indien monoplume,
chargé des de quelques dossiers du
Moyen-Orient. Et puis j'ai terminé en
euh en tant que chef du service de
renseignement de sécurité, c'est-à-dire
celui qui est qui était à l'époque en
charge du recueil du renseignement et de
la mise en œuvre des mesures actives en
matière de contrecriminalité, de
contre-espionnage, de contrerterrorisme
et de contreprolifération.
J'ai quitté ces fonctions en 2002 pour
en occuper d'autres moins moins voyantes
jusqu'en jusqu'en 2011. Et puis là, j'ai
pris ma vraie retraite et je me suis
retiré sous mes châteigners et mes
oliviers dans le midi de la France.
Coulou ta mam,
pardon.
Couam,
col tamam. E
mec
denier, nous on vit comme ça.
On a décidé de vous faire venir
aujourd'hui euh parce que vous êtes un
de nos premiers invités. Euh on se
connaît depuis que qu'on est tout petit,
c'est ça que vous m'aviez dit. Euh je
crois que vous m'aviez interviewé en
2013.
Donc on on se revoit aujourd'hui pour
faire un tour géopolitique
pour parler d'islamisation, de
radicalisation, de encore géopolitique,
tout un tas de choses. On a le temps et
on va prendre les questions de nos
auditeurs, de nos internautes qui savent
où les poser. Euh première question que
je vais vous poser.
Après
une épidémie, une pandémie, après un
début de guerre, comment vous voyez les
perspectives pour la France ?
Bon, alors écoutez, moi je suis pas un
homme politique, j'ai pas de légitimité
à donner des indications à qui que ce
soit sur ce qu'il faut faire, pas faire,
comment il faut vivre, pas vivre. Euh,
je suis toujours très gêné d'ailleurs
par ceux qui me disent comment je dois
vivre, ce que je dois manger, pas boire
et cetera. Euh c'est c'est pas trop ma
tasse de thé. Donc moi, je vais pas me
lancer euh sur le terrain sur ce sur ce
terrain de recommandation à fournir.
J'ai pas de recommandation à faire. En
revanche, ce que je vois effectivement
c'est que à la pandémie, on on fait pas
l'économie des pandémies, hein. On en
aura d'autres. Il y en a eu avant, on en
aura d'autres. Euh simplement faut être
prêt, faut être prêt comme euh comme on
on aurait dû être prêt euh vis-à-vis de
la crise ukrainienne parce que quand on
a passé et moi je j'ai pas de légitimité
là non plus à dire quelle politique la
France l'Europe en général aurait dû
adopter vis-à-vis de la Russie euh
depuis la fin de l'Union soviétique. Ce
que je constate, c'est que on a pas mal
refusé le le la main tendue de la Russie
où on a on a on a refusé de de fabriquer
un confidence building système avec la
Russie après 1990.
On les a un peu humilié quand même, faut
que faut l'admettre aussi. Et euh alors
ça, j'ai j'ai rien à dire là-dessus.
Moi, ça a été un choix de de nos
responsables politiques français et
européens en général. américain bien sûr
euh ça a été le choix de l'OTAN qui
avait besoin pour continuer de vivre,
d'avoir un adversaire. Mais quand on
quand on adopte une attitude pareille de
rejet- d'un d'un pays d'un grand pays,
d'un pays puissant et d'un pays doté de
l'arme nucléaire, faut prévoir le jour
où le l'ours va se rebiffer, hein.
Voilà. Alors, on pouvait pas à la fois
euh adopter une attitude assez hostile,
assez agressive vis-à-vis de la Russie
et désarmer complètement euh
déshabiller l'Europe de ses forces
armées en se disant l'OTAN y pourvoira.
Et effectivement, l'OTAN a vampirisé
pendant 30 ans tout effort de euh
construction d'une défense européenne et
on se retrouve aujourd'hui donc euh
totalement désarmé, hein. Les les les
contemesures que les Européens essayent
de prendre vis-à-vis de la Russie sont
relativement pathétiques et en
piteuse piteuse
piteuse si vous voulez. Moi, je dis
pathétique euh
pas très productif,
ça fait pas avancer les choses. L'OTAN
se développe, en a profité pour se
développer cette bonne guerre et il il a
sauté sur l'occasion pour intégrer
maintenant la Finlande, la Suède et
cetera. Bon, ce qui va pas arranger
évidemment la relation avec la Russie.
Mais en tout cas, nous européens et en
particulier français, nous sommes
totalement désarmés par rapport à ça et
nous sommes de la même façon, je le
constate et je le constaté, je l'ai
constaté en écrivant récemment un
bouquin sur le séparatisme
salafiste en France,
s'appelle comment ? cette pas vers
l'enfer qui est paru donc aux éditions
Flamarion euh au mois de février
dernier. Euh nous nous sommes également
des armé pour ne pas avoir pour pour
avoir fermé les yeux, pour ne pas avoir
anticipé que un certain nombre de
ruptures et de fractures euh dans notre
pays allait nécessairement provoquer des
phénomènes de séparatisme et de
violence. Voilà. Alors, il y a il y a
gouverner, c'est prévoir. Dans toutes
ces affaires, on a gouverné, on n pas
prévu.
Je vous coupe. Donc donc on n pas
anticipé, on s'est fait surprendre.
Donc on a perdu.
H
C'est pour ça que à la DRM, il y a eu un
directeur qui a sauté.
Oui. Alors ça, bon, moi je veux pas
rentrer là dans ce dans cette chikaya
entre militaire de haut rang. Euh la le
le à mon sens, la DRM avait bien vu la
même chose que tout le monde,
c'est-à-dire une accumulation énorme de
moyens militaires russes aux frontières
de l'Ukraine. Euh les analyses de la DRM
qui qui sont quand même pas des
imbéciles
de bonne qualité pour la plupart du
temps.
De bonne qualité. On on pensait que les
Russes étaient pas assez stupides pour
se lancer dans une aventure sur ce
lendemain parce qu'ils avaient bien
évalué la capacité militaire russe dont
on voit qui a été euh dont on nous a dit
pendant 30 ans que les chars russes
allaient déferler sur les plaines
d'Europe centrale et faire cliquer leur
chenille à la porte de Pentin. Bon, on
voit qu'ils ont du mal à faire 50 km en
Ukraine. Donc les les les analystes de
la DRM avaient dit s'ils se lancent
là-dedans, c'est ils vont à la
catastrophe. Ils sont complètement fous
et c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui. Mais
tout cela
résume aussi une profonde problématique
du renseignement et notamment du
renseignement en France en Occident.
C'est-à-dire que on a déployé des moyens
techniques énormes,
des moyens satellitaires, des
interceptions et cetera qui nous
permettent de savoir à peu près en
permanence quel est l'état des forces
ennemies, où est-ce qu'ils sont,
qu'est-ce qui se racontent et cetera. La
seule chose qu'on sait pas et qui nous
manque de plus en plus euh et et qui a
décliné beaucoup au cours des 30
dernières années, c'est le renseignement
humain. Parce que moi en tant que en
tant qu'officier de renseignement, ça
m'intéresse de savoir qu'il y a 4000
chars russes qui sont massés à la
frontière ukrainienne. Mais le graal du
renseignement, c'est qu'est-ce que les
responsables russes veulent en faire,
hein ? Est-ce que c'est la démonstration
de de ils montrent leur biscotu ? Est-ce
qu'ils ont l'intention de s'en servir ?
Et ça, on ne peut le savoir que par
renseignement humain parce que les gens
qui sont en charge de ce genre de chos
dans dans la plupart des pays, ils
racontent pas leur vie au téléphone et
ils se répandent pas sur internet, hein.
Le graal de l'officier de renseignement,
c'est le secret des intentions. Bien. Et
ça euh ça ne ça s'obtient pas uniquement
par moyens techniques. Les moyens
techniques sont nécessaires, ils sont
indispensable mais s'ils sont pas
prolongés euh par une capacité en
renseignement humain, et ben on file à
la catastrophe comme on a pu le voir là.
Alors ensuite, qui est des règlements de
compte au niveau de la haute hiérarchie
militaire là-dessus. Euh
bon, j'invite chacun à voir quels
étaient les rapports des différents
responsables militaires euh français de
du haut état major français avant
l'éviction de de
du général commandant de la DRM. Ils y
trouveront peut-être quelques éléments
qui leur indiqueront que c'était pas le
grand amour entre certains d'entre eux.
Voilà,
on continue la géopolitique, on passe à
Vous faites ce que vous voulez hein,
c'est
vrai. Donc on continue sur la
géopolitique.
On a une Europe des armées, une France,
une armée française qui est obligée de
mettre du cirage sur les vabses le 14
juillet. On a une capacité
offensive et défensive face à une
superpuissance dans un conflit de haute
intensité de 4 jours. On se cache
derrière notre petit doigt avec notre
vecteur nucléaire qui est très
facilement interceptable.
Pourquoi vous deinz de la tête ?
On peut en discuter le on peut discuter
de l'interceptabilité de nos vecteurs
nucléaires.
Comment il s'appelle notre missile là
qui nous a coûté ?
Non mais peu importe. Euh le problème
c'est que nous avons la quantité
suffisante pour que même si on n'est pas
au top de de la technologie et de des
nouvelles méthodes d'interception,
on en a suffisamment pour qu'il y en ait
un ou plusieurs qui passent à travers
les défenses.
Voilà. Et ça c'est tout le problème de
la dissuasion claire. Après tout, il
suffit qu'il y en ait un hein, qui
arrive euh au but pour que l'adversaire
euh se pose des questions sur la
nécessité d'engager le feu.
On reparlera du vecteur nucléaire un peu
plus tard. Comment Comment vous percevez
la position de l'OTAN, sa communication
? Comment vous percevez la position de
l'Europe face à cette communication ?
Vous avez regardé l'Eurovision ? Non,
très honnêtement non.
L'OTAN, est-ce que c'est un cauchemar
pour la France et l'Europe ?
Ben c'est l'OTAN l'OTAN a acquis euh sa
son propre sens de la vie, hein.
C'est-à-dire qu'il existe maintenant de
beaucoup plus qu'on le croit de façon
autonome. Il a sa propre existence qui
n'est pas complètement corrélée à celle
des États-Unis.
et il veut continuer à exister. Il veut
continuer à exister alors que sa mission
qui était de nous défendre de défendre
les Européens, défendre le territoire
européen contre une invasion soviétique
a disparu depuis longtemps hein. Alors
on me dit j'entends régulièrement sur
les plateaux télé mais l'OTAN est une
alliance défensive. Bon, moi je veux
bien mais j'ai pas vu que l'OTAN était
avait une vocation vraiment défensive
dans les Balcons.
J'ai pas vu que l'OTAN avait une
vocation défensive en Libye.
vocation défensive en Irak ou en
Afghanistan
qui sont complètement d'ailleurs en
dehors de du champ de compétence qui lui
avait été attribué
au moment de sa création.
Donc je à mes yeux maintenant l'OTAN a
acquis une vie propre a besoin
d'adversaire. Alors l'adversaire
chinois, il est un peu quand même loin
de la vocation géographique de l'OTAN et
il est peut-être un peu trop costaud
pour qu'on aille s'y frotter. Mais euh
l'OTAN a acquis une existence propre en
tout cas en Europe où on le il s'est il
s'est très largement répandu hein quand
on regarde la carte de l'extension des
pays membres de l'OTAN depuis 1990 en
Europe, on a pratiquement tous les États
européens il reste plus que la Suisse
qui est fidèle à sa vocation
traditionnelle de neutralité par rapport
à tout à condition de pouvoir en
profiter quand même. l'Autriche parce
que suite à des accords qui avaient eu
lieu en 1945
et puis quelques pays des Balcans dont
la Serbie évidemment qui a été une des
une des principales victimes de l'OTAN
et qui a pas tellement vocation à le
rejoindre. Voilà, la Suède, la Finlande,
on voit que c'est en train de se faire
aujourd'hui. Alors que là aussi la Suède
avait une vocation comme la Suisse à
rester neutre et la Finlande avait un
accord du type de l'Autriche où devait
pas ce pays ne devait pas entrer dans
une alliance militaire ou politique qui
pouvait se montrer hostile vis-à-vis de
la Russie. Bon, tout ça c'est des verrou
qui ont sauté et euh l'OTAN devient un
des acteurs majeurs de euh militaire de
la défense européenne euh sans sans que
personne n'y ait vraiment consenti, sauf
un certain nombre de pays de l'Est, les
Pays-Baltes en particulier, la Pologne
qui ont quand même quelques souvenirs un
peu cruels de leur relation avec la
Russie et qui à travers l'OTAN veulent
avoir le chapeau de la défense
américaine.
Comment on fait du renseignement humain
?
Comme comme comédit de Piaf dans l'hymne
à l'amour,
hein. Je trahi mon pays, je renirai mes
amis si tu me le demandais. Il faut
amener
son objectif humain à éprouver vis-à-vis
de vous ce type de sentiment parce qu'il
y a deux moyens stupides d'obtenir du
renseignement à mes yeux.
Torture.
Oui, exactement. La torture et l'argent.
Bon, la torture parce que la personne
que vous torturez va vous raconter
n'importe quoi pour que ça s'arrête.
l'argent parce que la personne que vous
que à qui vous le donnez va vous
raconter n'importe quoi pour que ça
continue, hein. Alors, le problème du
renseignement humain, c'est que ça ça se
fabrique pas en un claquement de doigt
et en disant tiens Coco, tu vas me
raconter ce que tu sais. Ça se fait pas
comme ça.
Même avec un peu de drogue,
[Applaudissements]
ça marche pas si bien que ça.
Ça marche même très mal dans certains
cas. Euh il faut c'est un travail de
longue haleine qui consiste à faire en
sorte qu'une personne vous donne les
renseignements que vous voulez parce
qu'elle a envie de vous les donner, pas
parce que vous la contraignez.
Et puis l'officier l'officier de
renseignement sur le terrain officier
qui est chargé de faire du recrutement
humain,
il est pas polyvalent, il sait pas tout,
hein. Donc il faut qu'il puisse avoir
confiance dans sa source, que sa source
vienne pas lui vendre le l'annueur
téléphonique du coin comme liste des
membres du parti communiste, hein. Donc
comme on peut pas tout vérifier sur
place, il faut avoir suffisamment
confiance dans
la fiabilité
et le et le bon vouloir de la source
pour obtenir du renseignement de
qualité. Ça, ce sont des opérations qui
se bâtissent sur
des années voire des dizaines d'années
sur la capacité aussi à recruter. Et
c'est ce que faisait c'est ce qu'on
essayait de faire souvent les services
soviétiques, ce qu'on fait d'autres
services en particulier services
européens qui est de savoir recruter des
jeunes à haut potentiel en espérant que
un jour ils auront ou certains d'entre
eux auront un poste de de haute
responsabilité. Alors évidemment, c'est
je finis c'est un truc qui est assez mal
vu par les ministères des finances parce
que vous allez euh pendant peut-être des
années euh
dépenser de l'argent pour pousser un
jeune dans l'administration de son pays,
pour l'aider euh
pour lui donner les les bons les bons
tuyaux qui vont lui permettre de
progresser pour lui que la DGSE ne fait
pas de renseignement sur le territoire
français hein.
La DGSE ne fait pas de renseignement sur
le territoire français.
On va revenir là-dessus parce que c'est
un point important. Euh donc euh vous
vous allez cultiver, je dirais un
chaptel puisque après tout c'est ça
hein, un chaptel de source potentielle
dont certains n'auront jamais de
responsabilité, vous fileront jamais
rien pour en avoir quelques-uns
seulement qui finiront par être dans
l'étatmajor de monsieur Poutine pour
vous dire que monsieur Poutine, oui, il
a bien envie de se servir de de ses
chars en Ukraine. Bien. Euh ça euh nos
politiques et nos nos ministères des
finances qui vivent à échéance de 1 an,
2 ans, 5 ans maximum, c'est des trucs
qui les révulsent hein. Et payer pour
rien, c'est bon. Cela étant et c'est une
des questions que j'avais posé à une
époque à un premier ministre de la
France, c'est combien vous êtes prêt à
payer pour avoir une source fiable qui
vous dit "Demain, mon chef de l'État, il
va appuyer sur le bouton rouge pour vous
envoyer une bombe atomique sur la
figure. Ça vaut combien ce monsieur ?
Bien, c'est c'est de l'investissement.
Alors pour en revenir à votre
distinction sur la DGSE
et anciennement la DST, la DCI, la DGSI,
la DGSE, nous ne sommes pas des services
secrets. D'abord,
coupons les ailes à un canard. Tout le
monde sait que la DGSI, la DGSE existe
l'adresse et cetera. Maintenant, ils ont
des sites internet, ils recrutent.
Nous ne sommes pas secrets.
Nous nous sommes et en particulier des
GSE, nous sommes un service spécial
parce que nous sommes le seul seul
service de l'État qui est habilité sous
les ordres et les contraintes de l'État
à aller violer la loi des autres, hein.
Ça se fait évidemment en dehors du
territoire français. Nous, moi dès que
j'essaie et dès que je vais faire une
opération de renseignement à l'extérieur
du territoire français, je tombe sous le
cou hein des du code pénal qui réprime
le le crime d'espionnage. Je vais violer
la loi des autres. C'est idiot de dire
que nous faisons dans l'illégalité. Oui,
nous faisons dans l'illégalité. Nous ne
faisons même que ça parce que sinon il y
a pas besoin de nous, hein. Il y a des
diplomates, des flics, des magistrats,
tout ce que vous voulez qui agissent eux
dans un cadre parfaitement légal.
L'ADGSI est un service de renseignement
intérieur qui agit, je le rappelle
toujours, dans le cadre de la loi et
bien souvent sous l'autorité du juge en
en particulier en matière de
contterrorisme et de contre-espionnage.
Alors des fois ils sortent un peu des
clous hein comme on l'avait vu avec
l'histoire des fadettes ou les histoires
du canard enchaîné mais à chaque fois ça
se passe mal pour eux
alors que la DGSE à l'extérieur ne fait
que ça.
Donc il y a une distinction claire. Il y
a la même aux États-Unis entre la CIA et
le FBI hein qui est un service de police
intérieure alors que le CIA est un
service de renseignement extérieur qui
comme la DGSE va violer la voix des
autres pour la loi des autres pour
obtenir du renseignement.
En terme en terme de contreespionnage,
en terme de mesures proactives pour
avoir un coup d'avance et éviter de se
faire surprendre. Vous avez plus de 35
ans de maison. Votre votre jugement sur
des agents de la DGSE avec des montres
connectées en OPEX,
c'est quoi ? C'est un relâchement ?
C'est de la nonchalance ? C'est une
carence en information ?
Alors, d'abord en en OPEX euh c'est ce
qu'on appelle
alors c'est quoi une OPEX ? Alors, une
opération extérieure.
Bon et alors là encore, on est en pleine
confusion puisqueen France, nous
confondons en général les forces
clandestines et les forces spéciales
sous prétexte qu'ils utilisent à peu
près les mêmes méthodes, mêmes méthodes
militaires. Bien, les forces spéciales,
elles vont mener des opérations à
l'étranger avec en uniforme et avec leur
drapeau.
La France revendique leur action.
les forces clandestines, c'est-à-dire
essentiellement le service action de la
DGSE, lui il y va sans drapeau et sans
uniforme et avec mission de pas se faire
prendre
hein, parce que là encore, on est dans
le clandestin
et dans l'illégal.
Quand on y va avec le drapeau et
l'uniforme, on est on reste dans la
légalité et dans le droit de la guerre,
dans le droit international.
quand on utilise des forces
clandestines, on est en dehors des clous
du des des conventions et du droit
international. C'est pourquoi c'est le
rôle du service action de la DGSE.
Alors, je sais pas à quoi vous faites
allusion en me disant que euh il y a des
gens alors je sais pas si c'était des
forces spéciales ou des forces
clandestines de la DGSE qui avait des
montres connectées. Vous savez euh la
DGSE, je parle pas des forces au nom des
forces spéciales, c'est pas à moi de le
faire. Je les connais pas et j'ai pas de
j'ai aucune légitimité à parler à leur
place. Mais la DGSE est une structure
humaine comme une autre hein avec une
répartition des intelligences en courbe
de gauche. Bien donc avec une minorité
d'abrutis pathétique de bon à rien et
même de mauvais à tout hein. J'ai
quelques souvenirs, je pourrais citer
des noms mais je vais pas le faire.
quelques génies trop méconnus, hein, et
puis une masse de gens ordinaires comme
vous et moi avec leurs qualités, leurs
défauts, leurs imprudences.
Euh ça arrive euh je sais pas quel à
quoi vous faites allusion avec votre
histoire de Montre connecté. Euh mais je
pense que
je vous je vous fais un petit
éclaircissement.
Euh j'ai un journaliste français qui
s'appelle Jean-Marc Manac qui a réussi à
remonter
des agents de la DGSE y compris sur le
territoire français.
Grâce à ça.
Moi, j'ai trouvé ça scandaleux.
Une incompétence grasse.
Bon, je je je ne connais pas ces fêtes,
donc je vais pas les commenter
particulièrement. Euh si c'est fait,
c'est une connerie. Euh il y a rien.
Bon, il y a rien à dire. Euh normalement
ça ne devrait pas pouvoir se produire
dans quand on en tout cas de montant
comme disent les vieux cons, ça se
serait pas produit parce que avant de
partir en opération clandestine, vous
passez au déshabillage
à poil, on vous enlève tout et on vous
donne
Oui. Non.
et on je commente le geste de ce jeune
homme.
Bon,
on on on vous rééquipe totalement avec
du matériel agréé. Alors si ça a pas été
fait et ben c'est une faute de
procédure. Voilà.
Euh j'ouvre une parenthèse question fait
d'hiver. Vous avez suivi un petit peu
les règlements de compte qu'il y a eu
vers Ans un peu dans le milieu de la
France où il y a des anciens de la DGSE
qui sont fait désinguer sur des parkings
?
Non
non encore revenons au renseignement
humain.
Qu'est-ce qu'il nous faut maintenant
pour les 10 prochaines années ? Il nous
faut quoi ? des bons formateurs.
Alors, d'abord si vous dites sur les 10
prochaines années, vous êtes dans un
temps trop court
de renseignement humain, ça se bâtit sur
une génération, 30 ans. Bien.
Euh ça suppose d'avoir
d'agir dans la durée,
d'avoir des gens qu'on forme très très
spécialement très spécifiquement sur tel
ou tel type de société, sur tel ou tel
type de schéma culturel de façon de
penser qui maîtrise parfaitement à la
fois la langue. Mais ça suffit pas. On
va pas, on fait pas du renseignement en
allant à Berlitz, hein. C'est très bien
d'apprendre la langue, mais il faut
avoir tout ce qui va avec la langue,
hein, c'est-à-dire le la pratique des
des habitudes, des schémas culturels,
euh des façons de faire. Euh quand vous
êtes dans le monde arabe, vous vous
faites pas comme ça pour faire vous
faites pas comme ça pour faire venir
quelqu'un, hein. Sinon, vous prenez un
jeton,
vous faites comme ça,
hein. Voilà. Bon alors il s'agit pas de
vouloir se faire passer pour un arabe.
Moi, bon moi je pas je parle je parle un
peu arabe euh plutôt plutôt l'arabe
orientalypen
ou l'arabe moyen. Non le sirop libanais
palestinien et ce bon importe
ou et on va pas on va passer notre temps
à ça.
On n pas le temps là. On fera ça,
on fera ça, on fera ça une autre fois.
Euh
oui. Donc euh il est pas question pour
un pour pour un français de se faire
passer pour un arabe dans le monde
arabe, pour un chinois en Chine, hein,
ou pour un japonais au Japon euh outre
outre les les différences physiques que
ça peut impliquer. Mais il est question
de comprendre ce que les autres disent,
hein.
Pas seulement les mots, mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière les mots ? Quelles
sont les et là on en revient aux
intentions. Quelle est l'intention de
l'autre ? Et donc la à la fois le
respect, je dirais presque l'amour, en
tout cas l'amitié,
ce qui va parfois loin hein, ce qui est
dans dans dans l'engagement de
l'officier traitant
parce qu'on s'attache à ses sources.
Est-ce que la DGS
et que ça peut devenir dangereux à un
moment ?
Est-ce que la DGSE plante ses sources ?
plantes,
les laisse euh en apesanteur sur place.
Ça ne se faisait pas de montant.
Je pense que ça s'est fait un peu après.
Mais bon, là encore je pas
on va pas juger parce que on est parti
dans ce qu'on appelle la RGPP hein,
réglementation générale des politiques
publiques avec toutes les contraintes
budgétaires
que ça impliquait. Ce qui fait que euh
les services d'enseignement et pas
seulement les services français hein ont
laissé tomber des sources qui parce que
quand vous avez une source dans sa vie,
elle peut pas être toujours source hein
parce qu'elle est pas toujours dans la
structure utile d'un objectif que vous
visez. Bon, donc il y a des moments où
ben la source elle donne rien.
Alors, on attend qu'elle est qu'elle
reprenne sa carrière ailleurs, qu'elle
fasse autre chose. Et mais elle pendant
qu'elle donne rien, si on continue à
l'avir, à investir dessus parce qu'il
faut bien médiatiser un peu la relation
et puis l'aider financièrement de temps
en temps quand elle en a besoin. Bon, si
vous coupez ça, vous coupez tout. ça
revient pas hein. Euh quand on quand
quand on casse une relation, il est
extrêmement difficile ensuite de de la
remonter. Alors il y a besoin de en tout
cas pour ce qui est du renseignement
humain de savoir investir sur le long
terme dans la durée et avec la
conscience que une source humaine est
pas toujours productive.
En terme de de contreespionnage,
qu'est-ce qu'il nous faudrait ?
Bah la en gros la même chose mais là
c'est un peu plus difficile parce qu'au
lieu de viser
une source quelconque dans une structure
économique, financière,
technologique ou autre, on va viser au
cœur de l'appareil de l'ennemi
de l'adversaire si c'est pas l'ennemi
euh de l'adversaire ou du concurrent.
Parce que en matière de renseignement,
il y a pas d'amis hein, il y a il y a il
y a des alliés
et il y a des concurrents et puis il y a
des adversaires. Bon donc on va là on va
viser des gens qui sont formés à ne pas
se faire recruter.
Donc le travail est beaucoup plus
compliqué, il est double. Et là, je
voudrais
dire que dans dans ma carrière, en
particulier quand j'ai été euh
responsable de des du contre-espionnage
à l'étranger, mes meilleurs
contreespions, c'était des
contre-espionnes, hein.
C'était nos petites irondelles
françaises.
Les femmes sont d'une manière générale
de bien meilleur contre espionne que les
hommes. Les hommes parce que ils ont une
certaine forme d'arrogance personnelle
qui fait que non, moi ça m'arrivera
jamais.
On me la fait pas, hein. Alors que les
filles, excusez-moi, ça va peut-être
faire macho, mais je suis vieux donc
j'assume mon matchisme. Les filles sont
beaucoup plus habituées que les garçons
à savoir distinguer parmi les gens qui
viennent les voir ceux qui ont pas des
bonnes intentions, hein. Elles savent
distinguer ça à tout un tas de petites
choses que que moi j'appelle finalement
de l'intelligence, hein, c'est-à-dire la
capacité de relier entre eux des fils
pour en faire une trame.
Bon, en matière de contre-espionnage,
c'est sûr que les meilleurs résultats,
c'est que j'ai que j'ai pu voir été
obtenu par des femmes.
Ça va jusqu'où ?
C'est-à-dire ?
Est-ce que c'est
qu'entendez-vous par là, cher monsieur ?
Comme comme dirait Pierre,
est-ce qu'on trempe le biscuit ou on
trempe pas le biscuit ?
Alors, écoutez, chaque cas est un cas
d'espèce, hein. Bon, euh, vous avez le
l'objectif qui aime jouer au golf et ben
vous allez apprendre à jouer au golf. Il
y en a un qui aime jouer au bridge, ben
vous allez apprendre à jouer au bridge.
Euh et puis il y en a qui bah oui, ben
OK, bah si si c'est nécessaire, on y va
hein.
Pour la patrie.
Ouais, pour la patrie et les armes de la
France. Le dit, c'est pas si fréquent,
hein.
De quoi ? La patrie ou les armes de la
France ?
Non. Euh, de tremper le biscuit comme
vous dites, c'est très élégamment. En en
venant ici, j'ai rencontré trois fans de
de la chaîne qui étaient en train de
discuter et et je ne poserai pas leurs
questions ce soir parce que c'était une
question qui était trop hée. Mais ça
ressemble au biscuit. Vous avez trempé
le biscuit un peu vous ?
Ça vous regarde pas.
Bon d'accord.
Non mais alors vous vous allez me poser
deux questions idiotes. Est-ce que j'ai
trempé le biscuit ? Est-ce que j'ai tué
quelqu'un ?
Ah non, j'ai pas encore posé la
question. Mais ça vous allez la poser
alors je vous répond tout suite. Je vous
réponds tout de suite. C'est une
question idiote
parce qu'elle n'appelle qu'une forme de
réponse. C'est non. Non parce que ou
j'ai tué personne et je vous dis non
parce que je suis sincère.
Comment on fait un bon interrogatoire ?
O où où j'ai où j'ai tué quelqu'un et je
vais pas me m'autoinculper moi-même de
devant votre caméra.
Comment on fait un un bon interrogatoire
? Bah là encore euh il y a pas de
recette, hein. Alors je vous invite
quand même sur ce sujet à lire un
bouquin de Volkov qui s qui s'appelle
Vladimir Volkov qui s'appelle
l'interrogatoire.
Euh ben il y a là encore il y a pas de
recette puisque en face de vous avez à
chaque fois quelqu'un de différent avec
euh
des des des points de faiblesse, des
points de force, des points de faiblesse
différents. Il y en a pas deux pareils,
hein. Donc vous allez vous adapter
au à la personne qui est en face hein et
essayer de de trouver dans tout son
système de défense, dans tout ce qu'il a
mis autour de lui, le trou, la faille
par laquelle vous allez pouvoir rentrer
et commencer à le déstabiliser pour que
il commence à parler parce qu'il y en a
qui parlent pas du tout hein.
Il y a il y a rien de pire que le muet.
le le type qui essaie de se défendre en
vous en vous donnant des détails sur
tout, lui, il est foutu, hein, parce que
ça ça va pas durer longtemps, mais le
muet
pas facile. Donc faut faut percer la
carapace. Et mais là encore, j'ai pas de
recette à vous donner. Chaque cas est un
cas d'espèce.
les Américains et le leur façon de
concevoir à l'interrogatoire. Euh je
rentre dans le détail pour la
communauté, waterboarding, réveille le
matin avec de la musique, de la musique
à fond.
Bon, résumons, c'est la torture, la
torture légalisée, d'ailleurs, je vous
le rappelle, euh par un par un certain
nombre de de disposition législative
américaine post 9/1, post
attentat de de du 11 septembre. Euh bah
c'est la c'est la torture avec les
résultats qu'on a vu, c'est-à-dire rien
hein. Si avec le résultat que euh
monsieur
Bagdadi qui avait été torturé au Camb
euh en Irak quand il est sorti là par la
porte du camp, il a dit aux Sentinelles,
je vous retrouverai à New York. Bon
alors il les a pas retrouvé à New York
mais voilà on a on a fabriqué
les tortures américaine que soit
Aboubamo
ou
à Guantanamo n'ont donné comme résultat
que de rendre l'adversaire
encore plus méchant
que ce qu'il était avant.
Commençons un petit peu le la
radicalisation de l'islam en France.
Pourquoi nos politiques n'ont pas vu
venir la chose ? Alors, si vous me
dites, c'est parce que ils ont un prisme
de lecture à court terme.
Comment ça se fait que nos services ont
pas réussi à les sensibiliser à ça ?
parce que le le le phénomène
le salafisme militant, celui qui mène à
la rupture et qui de la rupture mène à
la violence, c'est un phénomène assez
récent. Le le salafisme,
ce qu'on appelle l'islamisme politique
qui en fait est un salafisme politique,
c'est-à-dire une une lecture, une vision
de la société conforme à la façon dont
vivaient les salafes, les compagnons du
prophète. Bien, le salafisme politique,
il n'a existé que en gros dans les 50
premières années de la conquête arabe
après la mort de Mahomet et dans nos 50
dernières années. Entre les deux, c'est
pas ça du tout qui s'est passé. En 1945,
tous les pays musulmans et en
particulier les pays arabes étaient sous
occupations militaires ou sous statut
colonial.
Ils se on les a
ils ont conquis leur indépendance enfin
où on leur a accordé leur indépendance
entre eux 1945 et les années 60. Tous
ces pays sans exception de l'Indonésie
jusqu'au Maroc se sont dotés
d'institutions protodémocratiques,
soit des Républiques parlementaires,
soit soit des monarchies
constitutionnelles.
Bon, qui fonctionnaient tant bien que
mal. mais qui faisait absolument pas
référence à l'islam. On se souvient en
1954 de ce discours de Gamalabd Naser
devant euh devant le parlement égyptien
où il raconte, on on peut le on le
trouve sur sur YouTube d'ailleurs ce ce
discours où euh il raconte comment il
s'est moqué du grand du grand maître de
la confréerie des frères musulmans qui
lui demandait de de d'imposer le voile à
toutes les femmes égyptiennes et comment
il s'est foutu de lui et comment Nasser
dit que c'est c'est C'est c'est
totalement rétrograde, moyen-âgeux et
cetera. Et toute l'assemblée se lève,
elle rigole et applaudit.
Et c'est en couleur ?
Non, c'est en noir et blanc. Euh
bon,
il y a un truc qui aurait dû nous mettre
la puce à l'oreille.
Euh mais évidemment ça se passait dans
un tout petit pays qui s'appelle le
Barrain qui est une île dans le golf
Persique à 20 km de la côte de la côte
de l'Arabie Saoudite qui à qui
l'Angleterre c'était c'était un de ses
postes anglais sur la route des Indes
hein que les anglais ont occupé pendant
presque un siècle que ce soit le Qatar
Bahrain Abu Dhabi et cetera, Oman.
Donc le Bahrain qui est peuplé à qui
était peuplé à 75 % de chiit et à 25 20
25 % de sunnit a donc obtenu son
indépendance en 1971
après 100 ans d'occupation britannique.
Et les Bahrainis se sont dit bon ben
nous on va se doter d'institutions
politiques comme on les connaît
c'est-à-dire conforme à la monarchie
britannique avec un roi. Pour rassurer
les sunnites qui sont minoritaires, on
va on va nommer un sultan un roi sunnite
dans choisi dans une grande famille
sunnite et puis
qui aura les pouvoirs à peu près de la
reine d'Angleterre et puis on aura on se
dote d'une constitution et d'un
parlement. Bien, ça a commencé à
fonctionner comme ça. Ça pas duré
longtemps hein. Ça a duré deux ou tr
mois où une délégation séodienne est
arrivée en disant ça va pas du tout
votre histoire.
Vous allez nous dissoudre le parlement,
abroger votre constitution et donner
tous les pouvoirs législatifs, exécutifs
et judiciaires à l'émir sunnit que vous
avez nommé.
Là, on a vu hein les les premiers pas du
salafisme politique véhiculé par
l'Arabie Saoudite
nos copains
et nous on a rien dit
que c'est nos cop
personne n'a rien dit mais l'affaire est
pas finie parce qu'en 2000 en 2012
les Barinis qui commençaient à en avoir
marre de leur émir qui avait tous les
pouvoirs se sont révoltés rappelez-vous
Alors les les journalistes français
aiment bien les révolutions qui se
passent sur des places hein. Place
Tahrir, place Maidan, là c'est la place
de la perle. Bon c'est c'est ne rien
comprendre hein parce que
en général ça s'organise pas tout seul
sur la place. Non et puis non mais quand
on rassemble les opposants sur une place
en général c'est pas bon pour eux hein.
Ça se termine mal pour bon bref bref
même pas
là ça a été la place de la perle où les
barénis ont dit à leur à leur vieux
vieil émir sunnite tu t'en vas et on
reprend la constitution 71.
Ça a duré 3 jours
hein parce qu'entre-temps on avait
construit un pont entre le continent
c'estàd l'Arabie Saoudite et l'île un
pont de 20 km sur lequel sont arrivés
les chars séodiens qui ont aplati tout
le monde sur la place de la perle et
dans Manama dans la capitale du Brain en
disant non non non votre printemps à
vous vous le vous vous le gardez on nen
veut pas vous continuez comme avant
là non plus aucun dirigeant français ni
européen
n'y a vu malice hein. On a trouvé que
bon autant c'était bien c'était bien de
faire lych pendre machin et cetera
autant bah non ça c'est l'affaire des
séoniens qui
là on cette cécité du du de la vision
totalitaire
des des salafistes par les Européens a
contribué à à tout le reste. Donc si
vous voulez le salafisme
politique, celui qui a contaminé
nos nos jeunes en particulier nos jeunes
immigrés, il date en fait de des de la
fin des années 70 du début des années
80, c'est-à-dire au moment la révolution
iranienne quand les mola iraniens disent
au Saoud vous n'êtes pas légitime
votre famille famille Saoud, vous vous
êtes vous vous avez envahi, vous avez
conquis les lieux saints en 1926 au
dépend des gardiens traditionnel qui
avait été nommé par Mahomet dont le
dernier les haschemites he dont le
dernier descendant est le roi de le roi
de Jordanie. Euh vous n'êtes pas
légitime, vous n'avez pas de leçon à
nous donner. Vous n'avez pas de leçons à
donner aux musulmans. Alors là, les
Séoudiens se sont fait extrêmement peur
parce que quand même l'Iran à l'époque,
c'était 60 millions d'habitants. C'était
une très très une grande puissance
militaire et cetera que n'ont pas les
Séouiens. Et les Séouiens ont à leur
entrepris eux de de prendre le contrôle
de l'islam mondial pour y répandre le
message salafiste wahabite qui qui est
le fondement de de leur pouvoir de la du
pouvoir politique de de la famille
Saoude. Euh le
consortement américain.
Bah avec le Oui. Non ça euh bon alors on
va encore faire une incision.
En en 1945, le président Roosevelt de
retour de Yalta s'arrête en ba de Jedda
à bord du croiseur Quincy et où il
invite le le Iben Saoud, le vieux Ibn
Saoud à bord et où il conclut avec lui
un accord pour 60 ans 60 années qui
accorde le la protection militaire de
l'armée américaine à la famille Saoud,
non pas au pays hein, à la famille Saou
en échange du monopole de l'exploitation
du pétrole saoudien par la société Aram
Arabian American Company et beaucoup
plus important à mes yeux la garantie
du paiement du pétrole en dollar.
Bien,
accord conclu pour 60 ans, renouvelé en
2005 par George W pour 60 nouvelles
années.
Donc, on en a pour jusqu'à 2065.
Et pour moi, l'aspect important, c'est
la garantie de la cotation et du
paiement du pétrole en dollar américain
parce que ça fait du dollar américain la
monnaie de réserve mondiale qui permet
aux Américains de payer leur pétrole
pour Pinuts encore que maintenant ils en
ont plus tellement besoin parce que ils
produisent suffisamment pour eux et pour
exporter. Mais
surtout donc de faire de faire
d'exporter leur dette intérieure
colossale et de la faire payer par les
autres hein parce que quand votre
monnaie c'est la monnaie de réserve,
elle va servir à tous les règlements
internationaux et vous pouvez faire
marcher la planche à billet sans
augmenter votre masse monétaire
intérieure sans risquer d'inflation. Ça
c'est le problème.
Oui. Non mais c'est fondamental hein.
Bien. Bon donc on a on a cette cette
protection américaine d à la famille
saoute, je le rappelle, à famille pas au
pays. Parce que l'angoisse des
Américains par rapport à l'Arabie
Saoudite, c'est pas que l'Arabie
Saoudite produise plus de pétrole.
Queles que soient les forces politiques
ou les personnes qui viendraient
remplacer la famille Saoud, ils vont pas
boire leur pétrole, ils font pas
s'asseoir sur les puits, ils vont le
vendre, hein. La trouille des
Américains, c'est que ces gens-là
n'acceptent plus la cotation en dollar.
Mais
par exemple en rouble,
bah
ou en Yuan.
Ou en Yuan ou en euros,
encore pire. Non mais Kaddafi Kaddafi il
a senti que
c'était c tous les dirigeants de pays
pétroliers qui ont essayé de sortir
de la cotation et du paiement en dollar
ont eu des problèmes hein que ce soit
on leur apporté la démocratie
oui c'est ça que ce soit au Venezuela,
au Nigéria, en Angola euh bon la Russie
n'en parlons pas et tout les Iraniens
tous ceux qui ont essayé de de de sortir
de ce monopole du dollar sur le marché
pétrolier ont eu des gros problèmes.
Voilà. Et ça c'est en général assez mal
terminé pour eux. J'en reviens à la
vision salafis. Donc à partir du du
moment où l'Iran se montre un peu
agressif, les Séouiens ont peur et
essaye de prendre le contrôle de l'islam
mondial, hein, de en y diffusant le le
message salafiste. Les wahabites sont
des salafistes
dans le monde entier en prenant
en essayant de prendre le contrôle des
mosquées, des centres de formation, des
des centres culturels et sportifs
musulmans un peu partout. Je rappelle
que le le fils en Algérie est arrivé par
le club de football, hein. C'est c'est
pas il est pas arrivé par les mosquées.
Euh donc avec l'argent saéien, le
problème des Séoudiens, c'est que de
l'argent, ils en ont. Mais la ressource
humaine pour animer ça, ils l'ont pas.
Ils ont donc été obligés de faire appel
à des vieux copains à eux qui
finançaient depuis 1928, c'est-à-dire
les frères musulmans. des frères
musulmans qui
suite à la répression dont ils ont été
l'objet par nincer en Égypte se sont
répandus un peu dans l'entièreté
du monde arabe et islamique et constitue
ont constitué la seule véritable
organisation islamique transnationale
bien organisée capable de recevoir la
mane séodienne et de diffuser le message
salafiste et wahabite dans le monde
entier. en particulier dans les
communautés immigrées en Europe ou
ailleurs qui sont un véritable cauchemar
pour les Saoudiens parce que des jeunes
arabes ou autres musulmans en Europe,
ils vont apprendre la démocratie
ou en tout cas ils risquent de
l'apprendre et ça c'est insupportable.
Donc il faut les ramener dans le droit
chemin. Voilà. Alors à partir de à
partir donc du début des années 80, on
voit monter euh l'influence
salafiste
en Europe, en particulier en France, à
travers un certain nombre de
sous-groupes des frères musulmans comme
l'Organisation euh l'Union des
organisations islamiques de France qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui autrement, mais
enfin c'est c'est les mêmes euh qui sont
l'émanation de la confréie euh
internationale. des frères musulmans.
Alors ça on l'a pas vu parce que au dé
c'est les mêmes à vos yeux ou c'est les
mêmes aux yeux de tout le monde ?
C'est les mêmes comment
en ter en terme de radicalisation. Vous
parlez de l'UIF, c'est ça ?
Oui.
Vous pensez qu'ils sont radicaux ?
Bah oui, ils sont ils sont salafistes.
Et c'est l'idéologie des frères
musulmans qui est une idéologie
salafiste. L'idéologie des frères
musulmans qui a été théorisée dans les
années 1928 par Hassan El Banna qui
était instituteur hein. C'était pas un
religieux.
C'est euh le le monde musulman était
prestigieux au moment des salafs, au
moment des compagnons du prophète dans
les 50 premières années. Euh
toutes les innovations qui ont eu lieu
depuis n'ont fait que nous amener à
l'esclavage,
à à la domination par les autres et
cetera. Donc il faut revenir
aux valeurs des salafes pour bon c'est
il faut s'habiller s'habiller et cetera.
Il faut vivre selon la charia,
c'est-à-dire la route, la voie euh
désignée par les compagnons du prophète
au 7e et au 8e siècle.
Bon, ce qui correspond pas tout à fait
au standard du monde contemporain. D'une
manière générale, on le voit
on le on le voit tous les jours dans le
dans les comportements et ça les fautees
de culture, faute de connaissance,
les responsables politiques associatifs
éducatifs français l'ont pas vu venir
parce qu'ils ont confondu pendant
longtemps l'islam et le salafisme.
le salafisme qui n'est qu'une perversion
momentanée
de euh
de la religion musulmane et de la
culture musulmane.
Et puis alors du du coup on avec la
crainte de si on si on confondait l'un
avec l'autre de se faire traiter de
raciste, d'islamophobe, enfin les
accusations traditionnelles qu'on voit
un peu partout.
Comment vous Alors, question directe
est-ce qu'ils font du renseignement sur
notre territoire ?
Est-ce qu'ils font du renseignement pour
Est-ce qu'ils font du renseignement sur
notre territoire ? Est-ce que eux Mais
pourquoi voulez-vous qu'il fassent du
renseignement
sur notre territoire ? Pourquoi ? pour
se déployer.
Non, mais ils ont pas besoin de faire du
renseignement pour ça.
Ils ont besoin de faire du renseignement
pour aller pervertir des jeunes, hein.
Ils identifient pas les plus précaires,
les plus facilement manipulables.
Non, il y a pas besoin.
Il y a pas il y a pas des recruteurs.
Non. Alors, c'est là aussi euh qu' il y
a eu erreur, hein, euh c'est que le les
frères musulmans ont appris la
clandestinité et il fonctionne de façon,
comme disait Gill de Leuse dans dans mil
plateau, euh il fonctionne de façon
risomatique, un peu comme le un peu
comme internet, mais vous coupez une
branche d'un côté, pouf, il y a autre
chose qui qui se reconstitue de l'autre.
Euh il y a pas il distribue pas de carte
de membres
hein.
C'est pas comme les partis politiques.
Euh il ils ont pris les habitudes de la
clandestinité euh et ils sont un peu
comme les les
suprémistes blancs aux États-Unis. Il y
a pas de chef, il y a pas besoin de
chef. Chacun fait ce qu'il peut dans son
coin
à dans à condition que son action
s'inscrivve dans la stratégie globale du
mouvement. Alors, peu importe qu'
dévient un peu, qu'il aille à droite,
qu'il a à gauche, du moment que c'est
dans comme disent les militaires, du
moins que c'est dans la direction de
l'arbre en boule, ça va, hein.
Et là aussi, et on l'a vu dans les
émanations terroristes de cette
mouvance, c'est que on on on a perdu un
temps énorme à essayer de distinguer les
réseaux, les chefs, vraiment une
structure pyramidale avec un chef, une
mission, des moyens, il y a pas.
La seule fois où il y a eu, ça s'est
très mal terminé, c'est Bagdad.
À partir du moment où il y a un chef,
une mission, des moyens, un uniforme,
des casernes, c'est foutu.
Il y a une cible.
Ils sont morts, hein. Ils sont morts
parce qu'ils se désignent au cou. Ce
qu'il faut, c'est que chacun fasse le
boulot dans son coin.
Comment les les services de
renseignement se retrouvent relativement
désemparés, désarmé face à ça.
Bah, on est relativement désemparé parce
qu'on a pas de chaîne à remonter. Et
comment on fait pour les infiltrer si
c'est des frateries ? C'est foutu.
Ah bah exactement, c'est que c'est le
problème de l'infiltration
des des
groupes islamistes pour autant qu'il y
ait un groupe, pour autant que ce soit
pas une juste apposition d'individualité
qui agissent chacun dans leur coin, ils
ont pas d'instruction. On leur dit pas
tu vas petit, tu vas taper tel jour à
tel endroit à telle heure.
Non, on ce qui s'est passé et on l'a vu
ça à travers un certain nombre de
liaisons qu'il y avait entre des
islamistes français qui avaient rejoint
euh l'État l'État islamique et qui
essayait de se faire bien voir du chef
en disant "Tu vas voir ce que je sais
faire en France, ça va aller mal." Donc
les les ces ces soi-disants instructeurs
donneur d'ordre français, tout ce qu'il
faisait c'était d'avoir une vingtaine,
une trentaine, une quarantaine, une
cinquantaine s'il pouvaient de
d'interlocuteurs français qu'il alors
eux, ils savaient faire ce que ce qu'on
a évoqué tout à l'heure,
la programmation
et
il savait se ménager un chaptel de gens
dont ils étaient pas sûr que tous
passerait à l'action, mais il suffisait
que sur 50, il y en a 5 ou 6
sans qu'on ait à leur dire ce qu'il
fallait faire, quand il fallait faire,
comme il fallait faire. un peu comme euh
et c'est là qu'on en revient si vous
voulez à la théorie du loup solitaire
qui a été théorisé par un suprématiste
blanc qui s'appelle William Pierce aux
États-Unis euh qui l'a fait
dans dans un bou un bouquin qui est
encore au top des ventes aux États-Unis
qui s'appelle le Turner Diaries euh qui
montre comment un un théoricien de la
violence politique peut
en en serinant
le même message à des esprits faibles et
sans jamais lui mettre un pied dans la
transgression, comment il peut amener
des gens à commettre des attentats ? Ils
savent même pas pourquoi ni pour qui
hein comme on l'a vu avec l'attentat de
Klaoma City, Timothy Mcvey, qui avait
fait sauter un immeuble fédéral qui
avait fait 100 et quelques morts à
Oklahoma City comme une a bomber le le
le type qui envoyait des des colis
piégés à tous les amis qu'il aimaient
pas parce que ils étaient progressistes.
Enfin bon. On en a eu d'État aux
États-Unis qui ne qui n'avaient pas reçu
d'instruction de taper tel jour, tel
endroit, tel objectif, mais dont dont
toute la stratégie de de meurtre de
masse s'inscrivait dans la stratégie
globale de de d'affrontement que William
Pierce voulait entre les blancs d'un
côté, les juifs et les noirs en face.
Et ben là, on est exactement dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes modes de
fonctionnement où il y a pas de réseau.
Alors, peut-être avec ce que ce qui nous
vient de Turquie, on a affaire à une
autre une autre logique. Mais en ce qui
concerne les les attentats salafistes
qu'on a eu en France, on a affaire à une
collection, c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
trois ou quatre, mais une collection de
loup solitaires qui agissent chacun
sans sans sans instruction
particulières, mais
selon une stratégie globale qui vise à
la rupture et à l'affrontement.
Alors, une stratégie globale à la
rupture, à l'affrontement, là on est sur
une crise financière qui est en train de
nous tomber dessus, absolument
dramatique, qui va être le terreau
propice à toutes ces petites graines
fertiles pour se radicaliser.
C'est-à-dire quand il y a des problèmes
de travail, de chômage, de perte de
repère, c'est un terro fertile pour
recruter, non ?
Bon, toutes les études qu'on a pu faire
sur les terroristes salafistes en
général depuis le 11 septembre et même
après,
c'était pas des pauvres. Bon, ça montre
qu'il y a pas une corrélation
particulière entre l'origine sociale,
les revenus et cetera et le passage à
l'acte.
Un passage à violent, c'est pas la
corrélation est pas évidente. En
revanche,
le déficit culturel,
le déficit éducatif,
la rupture sociale, notamment la rupture
avec le père, les familles décomposées.
Euh eux, on ça on le retrouve dans tous
les cas.
Voilà.
Tout le temps. Le père absent. Oui. Oui.
Alors, le pai absent, c'est pratiquement
systématique, mais le l'échec scolaire,
la rupture la rupture scolaire, le la
rupture culturelle
euh
ça c'est on le retrouve à peu près euh
dans tous les cas de figure de violence
islamiste.
Alors là, je vais poser une question
très bête.
On fait quoi pour éviter ça ? On double
le budget du ministère de la culture, on
met des vrais profs qui ont le temps
d'avoir une classe pas surpeuplée
où c'est foutu en fait, on est contaminé
par des sectes radicaux radicales
un peu partout et en fait on va juste
attendre de seonger de l'intérieur. Bon
le passage à la violence
à la rupture Solfice, il est
multifactoriel
mais à la fois interne et externe.
D'accord ? Parce que moi, j'avais été
frappé par
le le le discours d'un de nos ministres
d'affaires étrangères il y a quelques
années qui disait que les petits gars
d'Ad Nosra, enfin la filiale d'Al-Qaïda
en Syrie faisait du bon boulot, que
Bachar Alassad méritait pas de vivre,
enfin et cetera, ce qui est peut-être
vrai.
Il a vraiment dit ça ? Ah oui oui oui.
Euh
mais et puis en même temps on on
interdit nous à nos petits jeunes
musulmans motivés d'aller sur le
terrain. Faudrait savoir,
faut faudrait avoir un langage cohérent.
On peut pas, comme l'avait fait
remarquer des diplomates arabes, euh
inviter un chef d'état étranger à monter
sa tente dans le parc d'un hôtel
français ou inviter un autre. euh à la
place d'honneur du 14 juillet pour 2 ans
après dire "On veut leur tête au bout
d'une pique."
Ça il y a pas trop de cohérence.
C'est une politique illisible
hein.
Comment on est arrivé à cette politique
ill ?
Ah bah ça j'en sais rien. Il faut leur
demander hein. C'est pas à moi qu'il
faut le demander. Moi j'aurais pas fait
comme ça mais bon euh là faut voir. Vous
voulez pas les chauffer les politiques.
Vous voulez vraiment pas leur leur leur
comment comment vous comment dire ça ?
Vous vous pour eux pour vous ils sont
pas responsables.
C'est pas qu'ils sont pas responsables,
j'en sais rien mais j'ai pas de jugement
à porter moi. C'est pas moi qui les ai
élus, c'est le peuple français. On a les
politiques qu'on mérite. Bon ben
peut-être bien oui hein, on a les
politiques qu'on mérite ça. Bon quand je
vois quelqu'un que Malin Jupé que que je
considère moi comme un homonête qui
admet 10 ans après que la politique de
2011 qu'il a mené vis-à-vis des
printemps arabes c'est un fiasco absolu.
Ce qu'il a dit dans une interview.
C'est pour ça qu'il était honnête à vos
yeux.
Bah au moins lui il le dit.
Il a au moins le mérite de reconnaître
que il a fait un mauvais choix. Il y a
pas beaucoup de politiques qui ont ce
courage, hein.
Ça pas ça n'a pas fonctionné, ça n'a pas
marché.
Ah bah ça ça pour ne pas avoir marché,
ça a pas marché. C'est pas faute de leur
avoir dit que ça marcherait pas
parce que
qu' a un agent de renseignement, on
saute du cocalan pas du tout. Un agent
de renseignement qui fait remonter du
renseignement brut.
Oui.
Parce qu'il est censé remonter que du
renseignement brut.
Quand bon d'abord un officier de
renseignement et notamment DGSE, CIA ou
autres ou MI6 n'est pas propriétaire du
renseignement qu'il recueille. D'accord
? C'est fondamental ça. Il n'a pas le
droit de l'altérer.
Il le transmet en brut éventuellement
avec une footne, une note de bas de page
pour dire "Je vous le transmets en brut
mais à mon avis c'est une connerie". Ça,
il a le droit de le faire. Mais le
renseignement brut, il il doit le
transmettre à l'autorité politique parce
que le la l'officier de transm en
question, il a peut-être pas tous les
éléments non plus pour en juger. Donc il
le transmet en brut à l'autorité
politique qui va éventuellement le
comparer à d'autres informations qu'il a
par d'autres canaux et puis qui va en
faire ce que politiquement il peut en
faire, hein. parce que c'est bien c'est
c'est bien gentil de dire ben les Séouis
ont quand même une grosse part de
responsabilité dans le développement du
salafisme politique et de la rupture et
cetera
dans les attentats du 11 septembre
mais mais bon le lendemain vous avez 25
chefs de d'entreprise à votre porte qui
vous disent oh ça va pas parce que nous
hein on a de l'argent à gagner eux ils
ont des sous donc le le politique est en
permanence en train d'essayer d'arbit
arbitré
entre des contraintes contradictoires.
Est-ce que je vous m'autorisez à
reformuler, essayer d'arbitrer par
naviguer pour pas trop pas trop faire de
remou, faire continuer le rondron
quotidien ou faire pardurer le
politiquement correct ? politiquement
corr c'est une autre problématique
don dont nous don dont nous sommes
gravement victimes dans ce pays mais bon
non ça c'est c'est c'est pas on n'est
pas dans le même registre
est-ce queà votre avis un un politique
est apte
à analyser des renseignements bruts
est-ce qu'à votre avis un banquier
est capable
autre que du renseignement brut
financier est capable de comprendre ce
qu'on lui fait remonter.
Ça me fait rire votre question parce que
quand George Pompidou avait
nommé Alexandre de Maranche à la tête de
ce qui s'appelait pas encore la DGSE
mais déjà le Zdec vous savez service de
documentation extérieure et de
contre-espionnage c'est un euphémisme
gaulois. Nous à l'extérieur, on se
documente, c'est les autres qui
espionnent pour qui nous obligent à
avoir un service de contreespionnage.
Donc quand Pompidou a nommé Alexandre de
Marangche, il lui a dit
"N'importe quel banquier de mes amis en
sait plus sur l'état du monde que votre
bande d'adjud alcoolique et de raté de
l'université."
Bien. Bon,
les petits épargnants spoliés par les
différentes crises bancaires
apprécieront sur le la connaissance de
l'état du monde par les banquiers.
Bon voilà. Alors, il y a il y a un
rapport difficile, il y a toujours eu un
rapport difficile. Ça s'est un peu
arrangé au cours des 20 dernières
années, mais il y a toujours un rapport
difficile en France entre
l'exécutif,
les politiques en général et les
services de renseignement et en
particulier le service de le service de
renseignement extérieur. Voilà.
Pour faire gentil.
Mais oui, mais
vous savez
politiquement pas correct, ça donne quoi
?
Ben non, politiquement pas correct,
c'est dire c'est c'est c'est ces
Séouiens et ces Qataris sont à l'origine
de de de toutes nos dérives
sociétales en France pour protéger leurs
propres intérêts. Moi, je peux pas leur
reprocher mais enfin faut en être
conscient et faut en tirer les
conséquences. C'est pas eux directement.
Si c'est eux directement.
Bah à partir du moment où c'est eux qui
financent les structures qui amènent à
la violence.
Je vais me faire l'avocat du diable. Eux
ils financent ces structures pour la
culture, pour la la religion, les les
choses positives.
Non. Oui, c'est essentiellement le le le
positionnement par rapport
aux règles de vie d'un islam du 8e
siècle qui vise à occasionner la rupture
entre les sociétés émigrées en Occident
et les sociétés d'accueil parce qu'on
sait très ils savent très bien que ça
peut pas coexister
hein et que donc nos nos jeunes
immigrés ou issus d'immigrés dans nos
pays d'Occident vont vont n'avoir qu'un
choix, c'est
soit de s'assimiler totalement aux
sociétés d'accueil, soit d'être en
rupture avec.
Et s'ils s'assimilent, ils sont
considérés comme des traîtres. Donc, ils
ont plus le choix que d'être en rupture.
Et
comment on dit traître en arabe ?
Pardon,
comment on dit traître On dit pas
il veut absolument il veut absolument
qu'on parle arabe. Euh mais on espion
espion c'est jetsous. Bon euh traître
l'arabe était une langue bien parce que
si vous je vous invite à prendre un
dictionnaire, vous verrez que pour
traître, il y a au moins une vingtaine
de mots euh différents. Donc il y a
différentes sortes de traîtres.
Et voilà. Donc
le but de l'affaire
c'est c'est pas de c'est pas de nous
c'est pas de nous islamiser hein. Ceux
qui nous parlent de l'islamisation de
nos sociétés euh
ça ça tient pas la route
hein. Les théoriciens du salafisme leur
but c'est pas de c'est pas de de
convertir les mécréants chrétiens
d'Europe de du pôle sud et d'Amérique du
Sud. d'avoir des adhérents,
c'est d'organiser la rupture entre
les musulmans immigrés chez nous et les
sociétés d'accueil qui est pas de mixité
que tout ce petit monde ne se mélange
pas.
Et là je vous dis Burkini
piscine. Là je vous dis Burkini piscine
à gren
mais Burkini vous me faites rigoler. Le
Burkini ça a été inventé en 2001 par un
fripier australien.
Bon, je vous invite à lire le Coran, les
hadits, la Sunna et cetera, tout ce que
vous voulez. Il y a aucune mention du
Burkini, hein.
Jusqu'en 2001, le Burkini était inconnu
des sociétés arabes et musulmanes.
Alors, c'est c'est
il a été inventé en Australie. Il a été
adopté
sous la sous la fule d'un certain nombre
d'imames proches des frères musulmans
par les par un certain nombre de
minorités musulmanes qui vivent en
Australie. Et puis de là, pouf, ça ça
Mais ça n'existe pas.
Alors pourquoi pourquoi milit c'est et
ben c'est arboré comme un signe de
rupture,
hein, comme
la barbe comme ça, la camis le le la
façon de s'habiller, de manger.
L'hypercératose aussi ou pas ?
Pardon ?
L'hyperchératose aussi.
J'ai pas compris. L'hyperchératose.
L'hypercératose.
La zebiba.
Ah oui. Non mais la zebiba c'est pour
montrer qu'on fait ces cinq prières par
jour et qu'on suse le front sur le sol.
Euh
oui, c'est c'est un mode c'est un mode
d'affirmation mais enfin il existe chez
des bons croyants tout à fait
paisible et pacifique hein ce
ce grain de raisin sec sur le front.
C'est pas euh
c'est pas tout tous les signes de
rupture sont pour ces gens-là sont les
bienvenus.
Alors comment il faut agir ? Comment
comment il faut gérer et comment comment
on fait pour gérer ça ?
Et ben cher ami, tout commence à au bac
à sable.
Le vivre ensemble, ça commence au bac à
sable. Il s'agit d'aller jouer avec ses
petits camarades sans les massacrer à
coup de pédrateau, hein. Il faut pas
leur piquer leur saut et puis il faut
essayer de laisser les lieux
à peu près en bon état quand on s'en va.
Donc tout commence à mes yeux, tout
commence à l'école et à l'école de la
République.
On s'est battu sautement dans ce pays
sur le sur la problématique du voile.
Faut remonter la problématique du voile
qui commence à Chador
dans les années 80. Non, monsieur,
commence avec deux gamines de 12 ans qui
s'amènent un jour avec la housse, hein.
Personne s'est posé. Bon, vous allez pas
fichu.
Oui.
Non, non, la housse le bon je ben
vous allez pas me faire croire que des
gamines de 12 ans à Cray sont se sont
dit un matin, je suis une bonne
musulmane, je m'habille comme c et j'y
vais. Il y a il y a des gens qui leur
ont fait mettre
hm sachant très bien que nos
une partie de notre corps enseignant et
de et de nos bien pensants français
allait comme se jeter là-dessus comme le
taureau sur la mouletta
et à partir de là faire du voile du
hijab et d'une et de tout ce que vous
voulez faire de tous ces signes un signe
de reconnaissance et de protestation.
Nos intellos ont foncé là-dessus, je
vous dis comme le taureau sur la
mouleta,
en négligeant les vrais problèmes,
c'est-à-dire le fait que il fallait que
les filles aillent au cours de sciences
nates, à la piscine, à la gym et cetera.
On s'est pas battu pour ça. On s'est
battu sur cette histoire de voile et on
a laissé filer tout le reste.
C'estàd qu'en fait, on a à moitié
déscolarisé
une partie de de nos jeunes immigrés où
on en arrive à des stupidités hein qui
ont été relevées à la fois dans le
rapport Stasiil, dans le rapport urbain
en 2008 où vous avez des écoles entières
d'un d'un certain nombre de quartiers où
les les élèves veulent pas utiliser le
signe multiplié parce que ça a la forme
d'une croix, hein. Ils veulent pas
dessiner un rapport orthonormé parce que
ça a aussi la forme d'une croix. Euh,
ils veulent pas qu'on leur raconte
l'Égypte pharaonique parce que il
pouvait rien y avoir l'islam. Donc euh
on parle pas de l'Égypte pharaonique euh
et tout on parle pas des croisades, on
parle pas de tout ça bien sûr. Euh
voilà, c'est on fait des coupes sombres
dans l'histoire pour ne pas pour ne
choquer personne. Euh bon à partir et ça
c'est parti en boule de neige hein. Euh
et on s on s'est pas battu dessus le
rapport Stasi comme le rapport au bain.
Stasie étant un aimable démocrate
chrétien qui s'est qui s'est fait
assister par 90 personnes qui venant de
tous les horizons politiques, Aubin
inspecteur général de l'éducation
nationale socialiste qui lui aussi s'est
entouré d'un panel de gens de de tous
horizons qui qui ont rendu des rapports
absolument accablants. Les rapports, on
on les a on les a mis aux archives à la
critique rongeuse des rats hein et des
souris. Euh on les a on a ressorti le
rapport romain suite à l'assassinat de
Samuel Patti. Entre-temps, le rapport
romain, il est resté soigneusement dans
les caves.
Bon, donc il y a il y a il y a eu un
refus politique euh de s'engager sur le
terrain des choses qui peuvent fâcher
parce que l'horizon du l'horizon du
politique en France, elle est au maximum
à 5 ans. Alors le suivant, il se
débrouillera avec. En attendant, on va
pas chercher les crosses. D'ailleurs, il
y a d'autres problèmes euh à à régler
entre-temps. Pouvoir d'achat. Quand vous
expliquez quand vous expliquez qu'en ce
moment c'est le Bourkign à gauche,
Bourkign à droite, Bourkign à toutva,
c'est quoi ? C'est une erreur ? C'est
pas une erreur. Il faut que la société
française se penche dessus, se penche
pas dessus.
pas compris. C'est un épipénomène de
tout ce qu'on pas traité avant
parce qu'on me dit oui mais alors vous
comprenez si elles mettent pas un
Burkini les filles elles ont pas le
droit de d'aller à la piscine. Mais qui
est-ce qui les empêche ?
Qui est-ce qui contraint ces gamines
d'un certain nombre de mar de quartiers
à s'habiller d'une telle façon et à voir
du monde que le bout de leur chaussure
parce qu'elle marche toujours le nez le
nez par terre ? Ah oui mais si elles
sont pas comme ça, elles peuvent pas
sortir. Mais qui est-ce qui les empêche
de sortir ? C'est peut-être la question
qu'il faut se poser,
hein. C'est pas les autorités françaises
qui les empêchent de sortir ou qui leur
impose de mettre de de se mettre sous la
housse. Bien, il y a certaines personnes
qui mettent la la le la tenue
traditionnelle
et qui se revendiquent que c'est
vachement bien parce que les les mecs
dans la rue les emmerdent plus, elles se
sont protégées,
des frères qui la protègent.
Ouais. Euh ça c'est c'est l'argumentaire
que les frères musulmans leur ont vendu,
hein. Bon et tu as d'autres jeunes
filles qui s'habillent pas comme ça et
que les mecs emmerdent pas dans la rue.
Bon d'accord, le le
Latine Lover est un est un peu chiant
par moment avec les les filles dans la
rue, surtout quand il fait 30 33°gr à
Paris que les filles sont jolies. Bon
d'accord. Euh
les filles sont toujours jolies à Paris.
Voilà. Donc c'est bon, c'est pas la
peine de les [__] sous une housse.
Alors elles vous disent qu'elles veulent
le faire parce qu'effectivement si elles
le mettent pas, si elle le revendique
pas, elle deviennent la la victime de
des grands frères qui n'ont. Vous saz
c'est le problème de ces sociétés là
aussi où ils sont où on est tellement
démuni moralement et intellectuellement
qu'on exerce le pouvoir qu'on peut sur
ceux sur qui on peut l'exercer,
c'est-à-dire le petit frère, la petite
sœur, hein. Ouais.
Voilà.
Les les Vous avez des préconisations à
donner aux politiques là pendant qu'on
est on est sur le sujet.
Changer de métier ? Non.
Non non non, moi je j'ai pas de j'ai pas
de jugement à porter, j'ai pas de
légitimité politique, je veux pas en
avoir et j' vivement
j' vivement tous ceux qui nous écoutent
à se méfier des pays où les anciens des
responsables des services spéciaux ont
une légitimité politique, hein.
Pas il y a pas comme Russie, hein. Je
vous rappelle qu'aux États-Unis, on a eu
euh des gens qui avaient la CIA comme
président des États-Unis. Euh c'est pas
bon signe en général hein quand euh Non,
non, c'est pas bien. Non, non, mais les
les politiques ont des nos politiques,
quel que soit leur euh
leur place dans l'hémicycle, ont bien
sûr leur rôle à jouer. C'est à eux de de
prendre les les décisions en
particulier, je vous dis, éducatives et
culturelles et et puis de reconquête
aussi. Euh selon la Cour des comptes
estime qu'il existe en France 1514
quartiers
de non droit. C'est pas moi qui le dit,
c'est la Cour des comptes. quand même
des gens sérieux hein, les les gens de
la Cour des comptes qui sont répartis
sur 800 et quelques communes qui
échappent totalement à l'autorité de
l'État où ne peuvent entrer ni les
forces de police, ni les forces de
sécurité, ni ni les échelons sanitaires,
médecins, infirmiers et cetera, ni les
pompiers, ni
bien euh
en tant en tant que vieux euh vieux
vieux débris des des en tant que baby
boomer, hein, Moi je coche je coche
toutes les cases de la haine ordinaire
puisque je suis je suis un boomer mal
euh hétéro euh
je fume et je roule au diesel. Euh bon,
je veux bien mais euh
il n'est pas normal que euh le l'État a
perdu toute autorité, que le le flic de
base ou le médecin de base ou le pompier
de base puisse pas rentrer dans certains
quartiers parce que ce sont des
territoires perdus de la République.
Alors, je sais, faut pas dire les
territoires perdus de la République,
faut dire les territoires de reconquête
républicaine. Et pourquoi on aurait
besoin de les reconquérir si on les
avait pas perdu ? Voilà.
que l'autorité de l'État s'exerce sur
l'autorité régalienne de l'État s'exerce
sur l'ensemble du territoire, ça me
paraît un minimum hein. Il y a sûrement
des investissements à faire dans ce
domaine. Donc on a on a ce problème qui
est purement de d'ordre public hein.
Sinon, on devient bah on se dit au Mali,
on accuse les autorités maliennes de pas
étendre le pouvoir régalien de leur état
sur l'ensemble de leur territoire. Mais
nous, on fait exactement la même chose,
monsieur.
Nous, la France n'exerce pas l'autorité
régalienne de l'État sur l'ensemble de
son territoire puisque la Cour des
comptes le constate. Il y a 1500
quartiers de non droit dans ce pays sur
800 et quelques communes. Bien. Ben
le minimum ce serait sinon de faire tout
de suite quelque chose, d'envoyer la
légion et
et les missiles, essayer au moins de
réfléchir à ce qu'on peut faire et puis
et puis de là rétablir l'école dans ses
missions et et dans ses droits, avec
droit pour les enseignants d'enseigner
le programme sans en éliminer euh des
pans entiers parce que ça fâche Pierre
Paulou-Jacques. Donc sensosurant.
Ouais.
On est on est euh on continue sur
l'islam radical, on passe autre chose ?
Vous parliez du Mali ?
N Oui. Non, le Mali,
ça se passe bien au Mali, on est
tranquille. Alors, le Mali, on s'est
fait bter le cul, on s'est fait expulser
à coup de pied dans le cul. Pardon ?
On est tombé au Mali, on est tombé dans
le même piège qu'en Afghanistan, que les
Américains en Afghanistan, hein.
C'est-à-dire qu' on s'est trouvé mêlé.
L'islamisme au Mali, c'est c'est pas
exactement la même chose que ce qui se
passe chez nous, ce qui se passait en
Syrie au Levent et cetera avec l'État
islamique ou les talibans en
Afghanistan. On s'est trouvé mêlé à euh
des querelles ethniques, tribales,
communautaire de trafic euh dont
certains se drapent dans le drapeau vert
de l'islam pour vous savez les les gens
d'action directe dans les années quand
j'ai eu à les connaître moi dans avec
leurs petits camarades de la route armée
fraction ou des brigades rouges
italiennes
vous disait à qui voulait l'entendre euh
non nous ne pills, nous faisons une
appropriation prolétérienne du capital.
Bien. Alors, on a un certain nombre
d'lamistes au Sahel qui
rappelle ce ce brave garçon euh chef
d'une bande islamiste
aux frontières de la Mauritanie, du Mali
et de l'Algérie euh qu'on a qu'on
appelait islamiste le jour, Marborot la
nuit, hein, parce que à l'époque ces ces
principaux revenus venaient du trafic de
cigarettes. Maintenant, on est passé à
d'autres trafic dans la région, en
particulier à celui de la cocaïne. On
estime qu'actuellement 30 à 35 % de la
de de la cocaïne qui vient d'Amérique du
Sud transite par le Sahara suite au au
au résultat des douanes américaines sur
la zone Caraïbe. C'est ça bien plus par
le golfe de Guinée et et les routes
saariennes.
Donc on a une intrication là dans cette
zone saélienne entre
les querelles tribales, entre les Aussa,
les Dogon, les Bambara les et bien sûr
les toirets qui voudraient bien quand
même avoir leur autonomie entre les
trafiquants en tout genre d'armes de euh
chacun se réclamant plus ou moins de de
l'islam parce qu'il faut bien donner une
une couverture respectable à sa
croisade.
Il fallait pas se mêler de ça. Il y a eu
un danger en 2013, un danger particulier
qui était celui de la prise de contrôle
de la totalité du territoire malien euh
par des des bandes de trafiquants.
Oh non,
mais les d'is islamistes non, ils
arrivaient à ils arrivaient dans la dans
dans la capitale malienne. Il
s'apprêtait à prendre le contrôle de la
totalité du territoire.
On est intervenu, je pense, on a même
pas mal tergiversé avant d'intervenir.
On est intervenu, on les a racompagné
comme ça s'était passé pour les talibans
après le 11 septembre, hein. On les a
ramené dans leur grotte puante loin.
Bon, il aurait fallu comme on aurait dû
le faire en Afghanistan,
s'en aller immédiatement,
laisser les Afghans se débrouiller entre
eux, comme le suggérait l'un des chefs
afghans à l'époque, Amin Wardock, qui
avait dit faut il faut nous laisser nous
débrouiller entre nous. Si si vous
restez là, il le disait en particulier
aux Américains, vous y êtes pour 30 ans
et vous allez y perdre des tas de gens
et vous allez vous faire haïr plus que
partout ailleurs. Et ben, on a fait la
même on a fait la nous la même erreur
euh dans le Sahel, en particulier euh au
Mali. Fallait pas rester.
Alors nous, ça veut dire qui nous on a
fait la meilleure erreur parce que moi
je me sens à vrai dire pas responsable
de ce qui se passe au Mali.
C'est qui ? C'est c'est le corps
diplomatique, c'est les experts, c'est
le renseignement. C'est qui nous ?
Bon, c'est un peu tout le monde.
D'abord, le Mali, c'est ce qu'on appelle
un ancien pays du champ, c'està-dire un
pays une ancienne colonie française sur
lequel la France estime avoir toujours
une responsabilité dans ce qui se passe,
dans ce qui s'est passé, dans ce qui se
passera.
Qu'il faut qu'il faut les aider. Ça
procède là aussi beaucoup souvent chez
nos plus hauts responsables de de de pas
mal de relans de néocolonialisme, hein.
Euh après tout, ce qu'on a mis en
vigueur avec Kaddafi ou d'autres, c'est
une réédition de la politique de la
canonnière au 19e siècle, hein. C'est on
va on va virer ces espèces de satrapes
locaux qui nous plaisent pas et puis on
va prendre les les bonnes mur au bon
sauvage. Ça en fait ça procède
de de de ce type de raisonnement qu'on a
eu aussi au Mali. Faut faut être honnête
par rapport à ça. Euh on va former
l'armée malienne. que vousz former
l'armée malienne, le le
former une armée euh au Sahel, c'est une
armée qui soit pas la garde prétorienne
du dictateur en place, hein, qui soit
une armée nationale. extrêmement
complexe parce que tous ces pays du
Sahel et notamment tous ces pays de la
côte du du golfe de Guinée quand quand
les Européens sont arrivés pour
coloniser au 19e siècle pour coloniser
cette partie de l'Afrique, ils sont
partis de la côte bien sûr parce ils
arrivaient en bateau et puis ils ont
pénétré à l'intérieur du pays puis ils
ont dit là c'est chez moi hein. Alors
moi moi je suis l'anglais, moi tu le
français, il y avait l'allemand.
Bon, on a on a donc tracé des frontières
perpendiculaire à la côte sans se rendre
compte que les communautés ethniques,
linguistiques, culturelles et cetera se
répartissaient en bande parallèle à la
côte. Ce qui fait qu'on on a séparé des
gens qui voulaient vivre ensemble et on
les a obligé à vivre avec des gens avec
qui voulaient pas vivre.
Bon, on en est encore là aujourd'hui.
C'est puisque il y avait l'intangibilité
des frontières en Afrique.
fabriquer une une armée nationale
dévouée à la nation et non pas à ses et
non pas uniquement à ses dirigeant
ça demande x génération surtout quand on
a laissé filer le truc pendant de depuis
la décolonisation c'est daté depuis les
les années 60 où ça nous arrangeait
quand même bien qu'il y ait quelques
attrapes locaux avec quelques militaires
d'opérette pour les protéger ça faisait
joli dans les filets.
Euh
et puis autre aspect des choses et ça
concerne en particulier le Mali. Quand
vous quand vous payez le gendarme de
base ou le caporal chef de base de
l'armée malienne 50 ou 60 € par mois et
que le trafiquant
plus ou moins revêtu du drapeau vert
viens lui dire moi je t'en petit, je
t'en donne 500 et tu me tu regardes
d'ailleurs quand je passe que ou
qu'est-ce que vous croyez qu'il fait ?
Il regarde d'ailleurs.
Ils sont pas tous comme ça au Mali hein,
surtout à la gendarmerie du Mali, ils
sont pas tous comme ça.
Non mais bien sûr. Heureusement,
on leur passe d'ailleurs ils sont pas
tous pourris.
On leur passe d'ailleurs le bonjour.
Mais oui oui,
surtout ceux qui ceux qui
cybersécurisme.
Il y a au Burkina, au Tchad, au Mali et
cetera. Euh au Tchad en particulier, il
y a il y a des militaires tout à fait
respectables, hein.
Bon euh mais
le Chad, le Tchad, ça se passe bien en
ce moment ?
J'en sais rien.
D'accord.
C'est pas c'est pas mon territoire de
coprospérité.
Euh comme disaient les Japonais. Euh
bon,
les le les noyaux de formation d'État
sont là, mais faut dire un, on les a pas
beaucoup aidé.
de il y a quand même des puissances
déstabilisatrices
Chine Russie
bah qui au nord au sud partout bon
que tout le monde y trouve personne
parmi les grandes puissances personne
n'a vraiment intérêt que ces pays se
développent he
c'est pour ça qu'on les laisse à l'état
de petit chiot et que que dès qu'il
commence à vouloir s'organiser hop il y
a un problème chez eux c'est ça
bon c'est un des aspects c'est pas
toujours ça il ils savent aussi très
bien se tirer dans le pied, hein. Faut
quand même pas non plus euh accuser
toujours le méchant ex-colonisateur.
Je vous coupe, j'ai une question
d'ailleurs qui est une question qui est
plus un commentaire qu'une question de
Radwan. Je veux je vous lis je vous lis
le la question. Hm.
Comment peut-on confondre salafiste et
frères musulmans ? Ah mais
sachant qu'il y a une guéger interne,
l'ancien chef du service des GSE disant
une aberration pareille me choque. Alors
lui, il a rien compris. Ben écoutez,
les frères musulmans,
les wahabites,
les tablis au Pakistan
sont des salafistes,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils se réfèrent
à l'interprétation de la loi telle
qu'elle était faite par les salafes, par
les compagnons du prophète.
Quant aux luttes à l'intérieur et en
particulier au luttes alléguées
entre
à l'intérieur des frères musulmans, moi
toutes les constations que j'ai pu faire
depuis les années 50, c'est du pipo,
hein, pour
désarmer euh les les
les éventuelles répressions. en ce qui
concerne
la lutte et les chikayas qui peut y
avoir entre les frères musulmans et les
wahabites.
Mais c'est mais oui, bien sûr qu'il y en
a parce que les frères musulmans
notamment en Égypte,
bon à l'origine c'est des c'est c'est
des épiciers et des rentiersin. Ce
qu'ils veulent, c'est gagner de l'argent
sans avoir à travailler. Bien, ils se
sont rendus compte en Égypte après avoir
monté un
système bancaire que qui s'est avéré à
être une pyramide de Pzi, ils se sont
rendus compte que ça valait pas le coup
de voler des pauvres, il valaient mieux
voler des riches
que donc leur objectif majeur ça devait
être les pétromarchies.
Donc je ne dis pas et je ne dirai jamais
que les frères musulmans sont copains de
la famille Saoud. Ce que je dis c'est
que la famille Saou a eu besoin des
frères musulmans pour mettre en œuvre sa
politique d'influence internationale.
Voilà. Bon, quant aux tableres
pakistanais, il ils sont pas euh
dans dans les mêmes mouvances et dans
les mêmes stratégies que les frères
musulmans
dans le monde arabe et et et en Europe.
Puisque le l'objectif essentiel euh des
tablisies pakistanais, c'est la revanche
sur l'Inde.
Mais ce que je dis, c'est que tous ces
gens-là utilisent les mêmes ressorts
culturels, les mêmes ressorts de pensée
et utilise le la même idéologie
réactionnaire, la plus réactionnaire de
l'islam qui est celle du salafisme.
Question internet. Un rapport sénatorial
préconise Un rapport sénatorial
préconise d'expérimenter la
reconnaissance faciale pour une durée de
3 ans. Il s'agit d'une actualité récente
en France.
Dans le domaine du renseignement, le
travail de terrain n'est-il pas plus
efficace que d'ouvrir des boîtes de
pandore de technosolutionnisme
entre parenthèses intelligence
artificielle à toutes les sources et au
profit de lobby point d'interrogation.
Alors, au profit de lobby, j'en sais
rien mais je vois bien à quel à à
comment les les datas individuels
servent à un certain nombre
d'entreprises
abus purement lucratif.
Dégsui, ils ont toujours ce moteur de
recherche qui fonctionne très bien.
Je sais pas, vous leur demanderez hein,
faites devenir quelqu'un de la DGSI. Euh
et vous avez été bien formé vous, hein.
Bah, écoutez, moi je je vais pas parler
au nom de la DGSI, hein.
Donc, j'ai dit DGSE. Ah la
mais vous avez vous m'avez rectifié et
vous avez raison.
Bon euh
comme je l'ai comme je l'ai dit à propos
d'un autre sujet, nous avons besoin de
renseignement technique. Le
renseignement technique devant être
notre première plateforme pour passer à
autre chose.
Bien,
bon si je m'aperçois moi que enfin à
l'époque où où j'étais qu'un téléphone
qui émettait normalement depuis la scè
San ou autre se mettait brutalement à
émettre à Karashi.
ou ou à Péchawir ou à Jalabade.
C'est un téléphone volé, vous inquiétez
pas.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Mais au moins, je
m'intéressais au truc. Il y avait
peut-être rien mais ça me donnait une
indication. Ça me donnait une indication
que je devais exploiter.
Mais ça le le donc j'avais besoin de ce
renseignement technologique, mais euh
c'était qu'une c'était qu'une partie du
processus. Alors là sur la
reconnaissance faciale, ça existait pas
trop de montant comme des l'autres. Euh
on on voit la façon dont c'est utilisé
en Chine par exemple, on peut
s'inquiéter. Euh je sais pas, c'est
c'est un débat à trancher entre les
techniciens et les politiques. Ça
c'est un débat tranché entre les
techniciens et les politiques.
Oui.
Le technicien, il va perdre.
Pas dit.
Pas toujours
mais bon le moyennes de surveillance de
masse, on voit que on a bien vu quand
même à travers le patriota ou autre que
euh
rappelez-nous le patriotacte pour ceux
qui ne sont pas de la même génération.
Et c'est une série de dispositions qui
ont été prises aux États-Unis après les
attentats du 11 septembre qui visaient à
organiser
une surveillance à peu près globale
d'Internet, des communications de de
tous les citoyens américains. Alors ça
allait jusqu'à relever l'identité et les
et et des gens qui allaient dans les
librairies pour acheter des livres ou
pour les consulter dans des
bibliothèques municipales. Qui quand ?
combien de fois ? Pourquoi ? Euh bon,
donc il y a eu tout un train de
euh de de mesures de ce genre, de
mesures liberticides effectivement dont
les résultats m'ont pas paru mirobolant,
hein, si je me réfère quand même aux
deux aux deux attentats de masse qui ont
eu lieu hier ou avant-hier aux
États-Unis. Euh bon, je me je me
rappelle aussi d'un certain nombre
d'attentats sur la côte est des
États-Unis. il y a quelques années où le
le les ou les types qui allaient
flinguer leurs concitoyens dans une
école ou ailleurs s'était répandu sur
internet avant en disant je vais le
faire vous allez voir. Gnana euh
apparemment personne n'a rien vu hein
de leur déclaration sur internet et de
et de leur communication téléphonique.
On peut s'interroger sur la pertinence
de de ce truc et sur le le résultat que
ça occasionne par rapport au coût hein
au coût à la fois financier bien sûr,
mais aussi humain, politique, culturel,
éthique que ça que ça implique.
Question internet. La DGSE a-t-elle
préparé des scénarios sur les impacts
climatiques, les déplacements de
population, de guerre, de famine, quel
impact sur la société française ? Bon
alors
la DGSE
prévoit
en permanence sur étagère des scénarios
sur
sur la possibilité y compris les plus
farfelus.
C'est quoi les plus farfelus ? Genre les
OVNIS Jésus
laissez-moi finir ma phrase.
Les plus farfelus qui peuvent naître de
la relation qu'on a avec des pays
étrangers.
hein,
quelle comment peuvent évoluer nos
relations avec la Finlande, la Chine et
cetera ? Donc on prépare
un service comme la DGSE prépare des
scénarios du possible de relation avec
des pays étrangers et des puissances
étrangères. Mais la DGSE, il y a pas de
faiseur de pluie hein à la DGSE. Donc on
nous ne sommes pas armés, nous n' pas
les les qualités, les qualifications euh
pour mener des études sur euh des
phénomène climatique. Je ne je ne pas
l'importance de ces phénomènes mais euh
c'est la la DGSE, elle sait pas faire
hein. C'est pas c'est pas un c'est pas
son boulot, deux c'est pas sa mission et
deux elle peut pas tout faire.
la DGSE euh elle avait senti un petit
peu que la la elle avait senti un petit
peu que la ceinture méditerranéenne
allait être déboussolé en 2008 ou pas du
tout
en 2018
les printemps arabes est-ce qu'elle elle
les a vu les bon
des révoltes
en Tunisie
en Égypte
et même en Syrie. La guerre la guerre
civile en Syrie, elle a commencé en
1980.
Vous avez fait tomber votre petit
mouchoir là et il y a mon technicien qui
est en train de raller parce que ça fait
pas joli à l'image.
Mon dieu ! Euh
la guerre civile en Syrie, elle a
commencé en 1980. ne s'est jama quand
quand un commando de frères musulman est
rentré dans l'école des cadets euh de
l'armée à Alep a sélectionné sur les 250
cadets qui étaient là à sélectionné 80 à
la 8 et les a égorgé au couteau.
Bien ça a pas porté bonheur aux frères
musulmans parce qu'en 1982 Rifat Assad
qui était le frère du président de
l'époque euh
en a massacré une trentaine de 1000 dans
la ville de Hama. Mais et là, j'en ai
été témoin parce que j'étais sur le
terrain jusqu'en 2010. Les attentats les
attentats islamistes en Syrie n'ont
jamais cessé depuis les années 80, hein.
Euh des révoltes, des mouvements de
révolte social, populaire et cetera en
Tunisie, il y en avait en gros tous les
de 3 ans
depuis la depuis la mort de Bourgua,
en Égypte. des émeutes du pain, il y en
avait là aussi à peu près tous les de ou
3 ans. Euh ce qui s'est passé en 2011,
c'est que d'un seul coup les les
les puissances occidentales et
États-Unis en en tête euh ont donné un
feu vert implicite aux révoltes pour euh
se débarrasser des dictateurs.
qui t'a donné un coup de main comme on
l'a fait en Libye hein
et en Égypte.
En Égypte on a pas Non mais
quand je dis de nous euh la Libye
c'était nous les Français mais en Égypte
c'était pas nous. Mais il y a quand même
en Égypte il y a eu il y a eu clairement
un un un feu vert de des Américains pour
euh pour pour faire une transition pour
chasser Moubarak. On a eu la même chose
euh en Tunisie avec une visite du chef
d'état-major américain au chef
d'état-major tunisien où clairement on
leur on a dit à l'armée bah ce coup-ci
vous vous laissez les choses se faire
hein. Bon euh voilà donc le le malaise
le malaise à la fois social, économique,
politique dans ces pays, il existe
depuis longtemps. Il il s'est passé dans
les dans l'année 2011 le fait que
ce sont les armées qui ont qui ont mis
Mubarak dehors ou ou Benali dehors.
C'est faut pas croire que c'est la rue,
hein.
Alors je vais je vais être provoquant
avec vous là. Ce que vous me racontez là
c'est l'écume des choses.
Oui.
Est-ce que la DGSE s'intéresse aux
tendances de fond ?
Bon alors écoutez, la DGSE déjà elle a
bien du mal à à s'occuper du quotidien
hein,
c'est-à-dire de tirage.
Non, puis alors vous vous me rappelez
une discussion moi qu'on avait eu euh à
l'époque de la guerre des Malin hein, où
euh
le président de l'époque de demande au
directeur général de la DGSE que disent
vos gens au Malwin ?
personne.
Ouais, monsieur le président, moi j'ai
personne au Malwin. Alors tout
l'entourage de ces beau dire bon à rien,
bas de plafond, poutre apparente
crétin des Alpes et autres. Bon, je vous
passe les je vous passe les noms
d'oiseaux, mais essayez d'imaginer ce
qu'aurait dit le président,
mon ancien directeur général, si un an
avant les Malouin, il était venu voir le
président et le ministre des finances
surtout pour dire "J'ai besoin de sous
pour ouvrir un poste de la DGSE au
Malouin
hein. Bon, on lui aurait envoyé
l'infirmerie du Val de Grâce pour le
ramener au galot.
Très bonne infirmerie d'ailleurs." Oui,
enfin, il y en a plus. Mais voilà.
Euh
les tendances de fond euh oui, quand on
quand quand on a éclusé le quotidien, on
essaie de s'intéresser aux tendance de
fond.
Ouais. Mais là vous êtes pas en train
vous êtes pas en train de me faire le
fonctionnaire qui est en train de
pleurnicher pourir des Non, je
pleurniche pas, je fais pas du
syndicalisme. On fait le syndical
pour les pour les tendances de fond.
Vous avez euh le CAPS des affaires
étrangères, le Zaps, on sait ce que ça a
donné le Caps.
Il y a des structures, pardon.
Le Caps, ils sont pas très bons le Caps.
Bon, pourquoi ils sont pas bons ?
Bah, les révolutions arabes, ils les ont
vu venir ou pas ?
Discutez-en avec eux. En tout cas, il y
a des il y a il y a des il y a des
structures
d'évaluation et de prospective, hein, au
niveau d' à peu près tous les
ministères.
Alors le problème ensuite c'est de
savoir si le SGDN SGDSN maintenant comme
on dit a la capacité de faire la
synthèse de tout ça et d'en tirer
quelque chose d'utile.
Non mais c'est c'est de la pougette ça.
C'est
chacun son métier.
Les gens des services de renseign les
gens des services de renseignement ne
sont pas et ne doivent pas
être des prospectivistes
sinon ils vont projeter. C'est pas bon.
Il faut des échelons pour la
prospective. Il faut des échelons
prospectivistes
formés pour ça, compétent pour ça.
Donc la question sur le réchauffement
climatique, impact climatique,
déplacement,
on laisse au Caps. Ah
ben on laisse ça au aux échelons aux
échelons concernés
et on n'est pas dans la merde. Non mais
attendez, vous vous avez en France, nous
avons une structure de renseignement qui
entre la DGSI et la DGSE fait moins de
10000 personnes.
Et comme on est en France, il faut
compter que un bon 5è de tout ça est
voué à des des tâches administratives.
Faire du café,
hein.
Faire du café ?
Non, quand même pas. Mais bon,
comptabilité, administration, compter
les trombones et les extincteurs,
il en faut. Euh c'est pas c'est
vous pouvez pas comparer ça.
C'est des portes d'entrée magnifiques
d'ailleurs.
Ouais,
on est d'accord.
Ouais. Donc
non mais vous pouvez pas comparer ça
avec les 16 agences de renseignement
américain qui totalisent 300 et quelques
personnes.
Vous pouvez même pas le comparer avec
les services britanniques qui entre le
GCHQ, MI5, MI6 sont dans les 30000.
Bon et qui et qui s'occupe pas de
prospective climatique hein
business. Bon euh voilà. Alors on a on a
ce là aussi on a les services qu'on
mérite hein. Euh mais est-ce que c'est
le rôle d'un service de renseignement où
est le dans une dans un problème de
prospective climatique ? Où est la part
renseignement ?
La part renseignement c'est déjà savoir
ce que font les autres.
Oh
b ça on peut le savoir mais c'est pas
ils font quoi les autres ?
C'est une question que vous me posez. Et
ben non mais je Oui, je vous pose la
question. Ils font quoi les autres ?
Et puis en quoi de savoir ce que les
Suédois font en matière climatique
ou en matière de montée des eax ?
Euh en en quoi c'est pertinent ?
Qu'est-ce que ça va apporter à la à la
collectivité nationale ?
Éviter de perdre du business. Alors je
prends l'exemple des révolutions arabes.
D'accord. On est en
Ah ben ça c'est autre chose ça.
Pourquoi c'est autre chose ? Bah ça a
rien à voir avec le des règlements
climatiques. Exement. Bah c'est nous
notre clé notre clé de lecture sur les
les révolutions arabes, c'était pas du
tout le bidule queil y avait de tous les
ans des révolutions, c'était la crise
énergétique.
Pas du tout.
D'accord. Je suis d'accord avec vous.
Chacun chacun chacun son rayon.
D'accord. Les révolutions arabes, nous
on les a vu venir.
D'accord. Donc notre clé lecture quand
il y avait un baril de pétrole à 14790,
on s'est tous dit ici ouille ou ça
risque de chauffer dans la ceinture
méditerranéenne. Et comme on bossait
comme on bossait sur le coût énergétique
depuis bien avant ça,
les phénomènes débilitants sur des
démocraties ou protodémocratie
ou protodictature ou ce que vous voulez,
c'est des facteurs qui quand même
excitent un peu. Queil y ait des gens
qui stimulent à gauche à droite pour
leurs propres intérêts. OK. Mais nous,
les révolutions arabes, on les a vu
venir. On a été sur le terrain avant, on
a rencontrer des gens avant sur le
terrain. Et les gars de la DGSE,
pourquoi faire ça ? Parce que la
ceinture méditerranéenne, c'est des call
centers français, c'est du business
français, c'est des emplois, c'est des
taxes, c'est la France.
Non, non, mais ça nous intéresse. Mais
le le problème des révolutions arabes,
il est pas venu de là.
Ah bon ? Le problème des révol Non, le
problème des
pour nous c'est la bouffe, la calorie.
Le problème des révolutions arabes, il
est né en fait d'un article de de Gram
Fuller dans qui était chercheur à la
Rand Corporation qui était qui est le
think Tank officieux de
la CIA qui qui avait pondu une note sur
l'inuctabilité de l'arrivée au pouvoir
des islamistes en Algérie.
Là, tout le monde s'est dit "Ou là là,
si ça arrive en Algérie, ça va arriver
ailleurs." Alors, comment on fait ? Et
ça, une notion qui avait été achetée à
l'époque par Hillary Clinton, par
Madeleine Allright qui était le ministre
d'affaires étrangères
de dire "Il on fera pas l'économie
de la prise du pouvoir par les
islamistes dans le monde arabe." Donc,
on va on va essayer de la piloter et de
la contrôler.
Et on va la contrôler comment ?
par par une trilogie magnifique qui est
celle des 3Mobility
Market
hein. Une notion qui a été rachetée
d'ailleurs par les les Catherine Ashton
et et les gens de Bruxelles
qui là aussi procède d'une vision
totalement néocolonialiste.
C'est-à-dire on va aider les islamistes
à prendre le pouvoir dans le monde arabe
et ensuite quand la main se fait mordre.
Non. Ouais. Bon mais
on on on donc on va les aider avec de
l'argent comme on a essayé de le faire à
Gaza avec le Hamas Monie mais en échange
on va le poser comme condition qu'il
laissent leurs jeunes venir s'éduquer
dans nos universités et cetera mobility
hein qu'il laissent toute leur jeunesse
venir étudier dans dans nos belles
démocraties d'où reviendront avec des
bonnes idées et troisièmement market
qu'ils adhè au système euh mondialisé de
marché qui, comme le pense un certain
nombre de euh
de philosophes américains mène
l'économie mondialisée de marché qui
mène inéluctablement mécaniquement à la
démocratie.
Bon donc l'idée ça a été en 2011 de la
part aussi bien
de de du département d'État de la CIA et
d'un certain nombre de responsables
américains relayés par un certain nombre
de de responsables européens notamment
au niveau de Bruxelles de dire il faut
favoriser les révolutions
les révolutions arabes. On sait qu'elles
sont menées par des islamistes puisque
et c'est les islamistes, les frères
musulmans en particulier sont la seule
force politique organisée qui a survécu
aux différents dictateurs. Mais donc on
va les accompagner, on va les aider et
mais on va on va avoir on va
conditionner
cette aide et cette assistance. Bon
ça a complètement foiré parce que Moné
ils l'ont accepté notamment en Égypte.
Mais laisser partir leurs jeunes
s'initier à la démocratie, ça va pas
non. Et l'économie mondialisé de marché
mais vous rigolez
nous ramener ça.
Mais non mais les frères les frères
musulmans, comme je vous l'ai dit, leur
vocation c'est épicier entier hein euh
rent export économie mercantile
protégée. Ils vont pas adhérer à
l'économie mondialisée de marché. Donc
tout ça est parti en en sucette. Euh
après et non seulement c'est parti en
sucette mais les occidentaux en
particulier les Américains ont perdu
complètement le contrôle du système et
et de ses dérives.
C'est
quand le chien mort la main du maître.
C'est ça
h
l'histoire du chien. La main du maître
celui qui mort.
Ouais.
Ouais. Question : Quel est son point de
vue sur le traitement de Assange et de
Snowden ? Quel avenir pour les lanceurs
d'alerte ?
Il y a il y a un problème de compétence
universelle de la justice américaine
déjà pour commencer hein. C'estàd que si
la justice américaine, pas seulement la
justice, le fisque hein, on peut venir
le fisque américain, si vous avez le
malheur de posséder un un fond je sais
pas quoi comme un placement où il y a
une action américaine et ils peuvent
venir chez vous pour vérifier. Euh donc
il y a il y a il y a ce problème qu'on a
accepté la Pax Romana, c'est la Pax
Americana et l'application du droit
américain sur l'ensemble de la planète
d'une part avec compétences universelles
que effectivement des lanceurs d'alerte
comme
ceux dont vous avez cité les noms euh se
retrouvent
avec no place to ride hein comme dit le
un copain de où il plus plus aucun
endroit
où se protéger de la poursuite
des autorités américaines alors que
c'était effectivement
des lanceurs d'alerte. Le problème aux
États-Unis, c'est que la seule façon
d'exprimer euh sa désapprobation par
rapport à un certain nombre de choses,
il y a qu'une seule façon, c'est de
faire ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est-à-dire
de sortir illégalement un certain nombre
d'informations. Euh ce qui ce qui montre
que les États-Unis ne sont pas un pays
si libéral et démocratique que ça
puisque il y a tout un tas de choses qui
échappent complètement au au au contrôle
des citoyens. Alors l'avenir des
lanceurs d'alerte américain euh bah il
est pas hein. Oui, effectivement euh
nous avons un problème global
de de soumission euh à l'autorité
qu'elle soit judiciaire, politique ou
militaire américaine.
Euh le fait que le dernier étage de
l'ambassade américaine ressemble plus à
une station d'écoute qu'autre chose. Ça
ça c'est pas dit hier hein. Ils ont
toujours eu des antennes partout sur
tous les trois. Les Russes faisaient
pareil.
D'accord.
C'est pas c'est pas une découverte hein.
Donc la reconnaissance faciale, on a vu,
l'intelligence artificielle, on a vu.
Est-ce que vous voulez compléter des
choses qu'on a pas vu ?
Bah non, moi je j'en reste à vos
questions. J'ai pas de euh j'ai j'ai
écrit dans dans mes deux bouquins le
celui que j'avais écrit avec Jean-
Guinel en 2013 sur euh la menace
islamiste mais vue à l'échelon euh et
les acteurs de la menace islamiste.
que soit l'échelon mondial ou bien dans
mon dernier bouquin là qui est plus plus
précisément orienté sur la violence
salafiste et les dérives de du du
séparatisme salafiste en France. C'est
c'est un peu plus un peu plus pointu que
l'autre. Mais enfin, j'ai là, j'ai
craché à peu près tout mon venin de
de de ce que j'ai pu tirer de de
et mon premier, vous savez, mon premier
voyage en Syrie, c'est en 1966. Fais
Alassade était même pas au pouvoir. Donc
ben j'y suis j'y ai vécu et j'y suis
retourné régulièrement
depuis. Donc disons que
la la cinquantaine presque la
soixantaine d'années que j'ai passé dans
ces pays que de l'Irak jusqu'au Maroc.
Vous étiez marié à l'époque
pardon.
Vous étiez marié à l'époque ?
Oui.
Vous avez des enfants ?
Je vous laisse continuer. Allez-y.
Oui. Oui. J'étais marié, j'avais des
enfants. Excusez, je vous l'ai dit, je
suis
femme et enfants étaient sur place avec
vous ? Euh oui, pendant au Liban,
pendant la guerre civile et puis en
Syrie. Oui. Euh oui, oui. Ils ont
toujours suivi sur place.
Ils ont toujours suivi. Ah bah, j'en ai
eu plusieurs. Alors, vous savez, on en
France, on est on est
professeur de français.
Ah non non, moi je je suis pas mal
autru. Moi euh d'ailleurs le vous
m'expliquerez comment un mec sous
couverture de professeur de français
peut vivre pendant 7 ans à Damas en plus
en sautant la femme d'un pome du régime
sans sans avoir d'ennui
en ayant gardé tous ses ongles. C'est
ça.
Ah mais non mais j'ai adoré le j'ai
adoré cette série parce que elle est
divertissante, c'estint c'est bien joué
des légendes.
Oui, c'est c'est bien réalisé. C'est
c'est moi j'avais j'ai j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à le regarder. Cela
dit, c'est c'est plein
d'invraissemblance. C'est dommage parce
que Rochamp en revanche avait
avait une grande qualité de de
d'observation. Il avait fait un film
extraordinaire qui lui était très proche
de la réalité qui s'appelait Les
Patriotes euh que que j'invite tout le
monde à regarder pour savoir ce que
c'est que le renseignement humain. Euh
mais bon non
j'étais pas sous couverture de
professeur de français. J'ai été sous
couverture diplomatique et puis sous
couverture pas diplomatique. Ce qui est
ce qui ce qui manifeste d'ailleurs
beaucoup de d'ignorance de de nos
responsables
même des services parce que
le le Liban par exemple ou même la Syrie
euh tout le monde se connaît quand vous
y avez été une fois avec une couverture
diplomatique et que vous revenez pour
vendre des cigares de bon vous êtes
repéré. Après, c'est c'est euh c'est
c'est votre problème de d'essayer de
vous faire admettre quand même et de
faire votre boulot euh
de la façon la plus efficace possible.
Voilà. Donc de
le fait, je vous coupe, désolé.
Le fait que le la France expulse des
diplomates, le fait que la Russie
expulse des diplomates,
ça va monter encore en puissance ces
petites histoires où ça fait partie du
folklore de je vire les tiens, ensuite
je vire les miens ou inversement.
Bon, fallait donner un signal parce que
bon, on sait très bien que dans une dans
une représentation, ça a pas beaucoup
changé entre l'Union Soviétique et la
Russie, dans une représentation
diplomatique russe, il y a la moitié des
gens qui se font partie des services et
puis l'autre moitié qui travaille pour
eux, hein. Donc
c'est un état totalitaire que vous le
vouliez ou non. Donc tout le monde
collabore euh
à l'inform
des service.
J'étais enor
C'est quoi ça ? C'est quelle orchestre
déjà ?
J'étais pourtant en mode avion. Euh
c'est une alarme.
Oui.
Euh oui. Donc euh
on sait très bien qu'une ambassade russe
c'est une ambassade russe avec
euh tout ce tout tout ce que ça
comporte. Mais enfin nos amis américains
sont pas avar non plus en en personnel
des rattachés au ils ont quand même 16
agences de renseignement. Alors, faut
bien que tout ce petit monde se retrouve
quelque part entre et notamment les plus
importantes, le la CIA, le FBI, la la
DIA et la NSA, euh les ambassades sont
des des structures de couverture aussi
pour les pour les grands services.
Question internet, c'est quoi un vrai
allié dans le domaine du renseignement ?
Il y a pas
Il y a pas de vrai allié dans le domaine
du renseignement.
parce qu'on peut très bien être allié
sur un sur une certaine problématique et
concurrent sur une autre.
Est-ce que le renseignement c'est un
métier de roi fait par des truants ?
Bon, écoutez, je j'ai pas fait un métier
de roi et je pense pas être intru, hein,
hein. Alors, je sais bien que répondu
euh Non, mais je sais bien que un un un
ancien officier de de renseignement de
euh de l'AP Vert qui avait été
reconverti,
qui était à l'origine de la création du
BND, euh avait dit que le métier le
métier du renseignement est un métier de
seigneur.
Bon, j'aime bien la formulation, mais
enfin c'est pas c'est pas plus un métier
de de seigneur qu'un autre. Et je pense
qu'il faut qu'il soit fait par des gens
honnêtes et en tout cas respectueux du
service de l'État et de leurs
concitoyens.
C'est quoi un patriote ?
Vous saz en France un patriote c'est
quelqu'un d'extrême droite hein.
Ah non
bah mettez un drapeau français à votre
fenêtre et vous allez voir ce que vont
dire vos voisins.
Bon que vous êtes un gars de la marine
hein. Si vous mettez un un un drapeau un
drapeau français à votre fenêtre.
Voilà. Alors qu'est-ce que c'est être un
patriote ? c'est je crois avoir à la
fois l'amour de son pays. Non non non
pas parce que c'est tracé sur une carte
mais l'amour de sa culture, de sa langue
et de ses concitoyens.
C'est ça être patriote et d'être prêt à
le défendre auprès d'un certain nombre
de sacrifices s'il est attaqué.
Comment vous expliquez que le drapeau
français c'est considéré comme d'être
extrême droite ?
Ben j'explique pas. C'est une c'est une
dérive culturelle de notre société.
quand vous allez aux États-Unis et
pratiquement euh chaque maison, il y a
un drapeau américain à la fenêtre, hein.
Et
y compris les Américains en France,
compris les Américains en France qui
mettent un drapeau américain chez eux.
Euh
comment on en est arrivé là ? Là, il y a
ça fait partie sûrement
des données sociologiques, culturelles
qu'il faudrait étudier parce que ça a
certainement un rapport avec les la
progression du séparatisme dans ce pays.
Question internet, nos alliés sont de de
qui de qui ? Des pays extérieurs à la
France, désolé, c'est mal présenté. Ceux
qui nous écoutent le plus, c'est qui ?
On intéresse qui en ce moment ? On
n'intéresse plus personne ou ou c'est
juste pour le décorum ? Bon, pas
d'abord, tous les services de
renseignement ont leur logique
d'entreprise. Donc, on rase tous les
clients et on écoute que qui on peut,
hein, autant qu'on peut. Euh alors, à
savoir est-ce qu'on intéresse beaucoup ?
Euh, bon euh comme l'ont constaté euh
un certain nombre de nos hommes
politiques, nous ne sommes plus une
grande puissance. Nous sommes une
puissance moyenne, hein,
de moyenne impuissance.
Voilà.
Question internet. Comment les officiers
sont-ils formés au niveau linguistique ?
C'est un déterminant essentiel pour la
confiance.
Oui, ben ceux qui doivent aller sur le
terrain, bien sûr, bah ils sont formés.
D'abord, on est ils essayent de les
recruter parmi ceux qui sont déjà
formés, que ce soit en fa langues
orientales et cetera et puis ensuite on
les perfectionne.
Il y a plusieurs cycles de
perfectionnement y compris souvent sur
le terrain quand c'est possible.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
nous conseiller, trois livres à nous
conseiller ?
Ah ben les miens
non, ça c'est interdit ça.
Ah bon ? Vous avez un avis sur le le la
suppression du corps diplomatique ?
C'est une décision du président de la
République. Il est élu, fait ce qu'il
veut. Je je pense qu'on se prive d'un
d'un
instrument séculaire
euh qui avait
ses bons côtés et ses côtés un peu
désouets ou euh ou trop formaliste, mais
euh qui avait aussi euh des solidarités
et une une expérience
du terrain qui était absolument
indispensable
à la à la compréhension qu'on peut avoir
votre époque
des pays étangés. Non, c'est encore vrai
aujourd'hui. Bon, alors je vois bien je
vois bien où ça va la suppression du
cord diplomatique, c'est que ça va
permettre d'amplifier euh la capacité de
l'exécutif à nommer ambassadeur
n'importe qui, hein, comme on le fait
comme ça se passe aux États-Unis. Euh
autant que j'en ai vu euh quand ça s'est
produit euh ces ces dernières années ou
ces dernières décennies, ça a pas donné
des résultats mirbolants, hein. Il faut
ambassadeur, c'est un vrai métier.
C'est un vrai métier euh avec ses
contraintes, ses lois, ses règles,
tout le monde n'est pas capable de le
faire.
Donc trois livres à nous conseiller.
Je suis pas sûr d'avoir trois livres à
vous conseiller puisque j'ai pas le
droit de citer les miens. Non,
j'aimerais que
après
D'accord.
Bon, il faut faut lire les bouquins de
les bouquins de Jean Guinel.
Il y il en a plusieurs sur le sur les
les les l'histoire des services
l'histoire politique des services
français sur
le le le fonctionnement du service et
cetera. C'est essentiellement euh lui
que qui pendant euh 50 ans aussi a été a
été le mieux placé comme journaliste euh
auprès des services pour en donner une
vue euh sans fantasme, euh sans
connivance euh
et sans concession
et et pas un autre auteur. Non, mais il
en a écrit.
Vous avez un intéressement au bénéfice
ou du tout vous avez un intéressement au
bénéfices chez Jean- Guinel ?
Aucun.
Bon, question internet. Quel est son
plus beau souvenir en tant que ancien
chef de sécurité à la DGSE ? Il y a des
beaux souvenirs à la DGSE.
Je me suis couché tard.
Oh, magnifique.
Voilà.
Et et le transit intestinal s'est bien
passé ?
Ah, tout à fait. Alors là, aucun
problème de ce côté-là.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
C'est un beau métier. C'est on est on si
on le veut, on peut on peut y vivre sans
vie en une vie,
mais
faut mettre sa fierté
derrière soi. Il y aura jamais de
reconnaissance si ce n'est celle de vos
de vos collègues, de vos pères ou
autres. Quoi que vous fassiez, vous vous
n'aurez pas le de de reconnaissance.
Mais euh vous aurez une vie une vie de
souvenir que personne d'autre ne peut
avoir.
Mais qui a besoin de reconnaissance
quand on protège le pays ? Oh
racontez pas des sornettes. Tout le
monde aime être connu et aimé. Vous
connaissez beaucoup de gens qui aiment
pas être connus et qui aiment pas être
aimés ?
Et des mecs qui travaillent dans les
services de renseignement, vaut mieux
pas être connu. Non. Ben non, il reconnu
au sens de reconnaissance
de vos concitoyens. Que qu'on les
reconnaisse pas dans la rue, c'est un
notre problème,
hein. Mais euh
enregistrer la satisfaction de l'État
employeur, donc du citoyen à travers
l'État employeur ou que on vous dise de
temps en temps c'était bien petit, c'est
pas désagréable hein, tout le monde aime
ça.
C'était bien petit.
Bah oui.
Alain Chouet, merci. Merci à vous. Merci
de votre attention.
[Musique]